Auf jeden Fall das meiste Interesse. Aber für wen sind die anfallenden Datenmassen tatsächlich von größtem Wert? CNN und CIA investieren heute weit mehr Geld in das Internet, als es sich die Bundesregierung für sich wohl auch nur vorstellen könnte. Das Internet ist Spielplatz und Datenquelle gleichermaßen. Sind alle erst einmal am großen Netz, dann gewinnen auch die Begriffe Lauschangriff und Datenspur eine völlig neue Dimension. Die Realtime-Überwachung der Bevölkerung ist aber nur ein Aspekt. Welche Auswirkungen hat das Internet auf die Privatbevölkerung? Nimmt die Isolation zu oder ist das Webterminal ein Ausweg aus der Einsamkeit? Ist die virtuelle Krankenpflege ein Zugewinn oder nur eine billige Methode, Dienst der Menschen einzusparen?
Wir müssen sowieso erst einen Mikrocheck machen. Es gibt übrigens auch ein Voting heute, dazu aber mehr. Testtest.
Test, du Sterron.
Chaos Computer Club ist hier mit neun Anwesenden. Mech. Mech, du darfst anfangen.
Hallo, ich bin Mech. Schön, ich bin heute zum ersten Mal hier. Ich werde hier als Internet-Experte gehandelt. Das freut mich erst mal.
Stimmt das auch?
Das stimmt. Ja, natürlich.
Wie wird man ein Internet-Experte?
Man lässt sich von anderen so nennen.
Die anderen machen einen zum Internet-Experte.
Wie lange hast du eine eigene E-Mail-Adresse?
Seit 1991 kann das sein.
Wir wohnen jetzt 5 Jahre an der Datenautobahn. Haben Sie irgendwelche Schaden davon getragen?
Nein.
Meine allergrößte Angst im Internet ist, dass das Internet genauso wird, wie das Fernsehen jetzt schon ist und Radio auch einigermaßen auf vieles und Zeitung ist und überhaupt alles voller Werbung ist. Und das Allerschlimmste, was mir im letzten Jahr passiert ist, war die Langnese Blisseiscreme Werbesite.
Was war das auch?
Langnese-Eiscreme www.langnese.de Das ist das Schlimmste, was mir passiert ist und ich habe große Angst davor, dass alles genauso wird, wie das war.
Bitte klicken Sie jetzt.
Gut, ich klicke auf Tim, Hi Tim. Deine größte Angst?
Deine größte Angst, dass Erdbeam stürmt. Es ist eher eine Gewissheit. Meine These ist, dass Sie alle durchdrehen werden. Ich denke, das Internet ist jetzt genau das richtige Medium, um das auf den Weg zu gehen.
Dass wir alle durchdrehen?
Wir alle, also nicht nur wir alle, sondern eigentlich überhaupt alle. Also ich sehe die größte Angst im Internet, mal ernst zu bleiben, einfach in den sozialen Auswirkungen, in den privaten sozialen Auswirkungen.
Also Vereinsamung?
Ich würde es gar nicht mal so sehr auf die Vereinsamung bringen, aber vielleicht so, dass Thema weniger auf direkten Kontakt angewiesen sein müssen. Klickst du weiter? Ich bleibe hart.
Klick weiter, wir haben noch ein paar Leute über vorstellen müssen, so meine ich das.
Ich bin dran, Entschuldigung, ich bin Steini und ich habe auch Angst, aber nicht vor dem Internet, nein, das Internet ist toll, ich habe Angst vor den Leuten hinter dem Internet. Ich habe Angst vor den Leuten, die das benutzen, die sagen wir mal auf der ganzen Welt sowieso schon ziemlich, naja, so ein bisschen komisch sind, aber die jetzt im Internet auch noch ein Medium haben, das laut und deutlich und überall zum Ausdruck zu bringen und das macht mir Angst, so ein bisschen zumindest.
Steini, hast du nicht mehr Angst davor, wenn die Leute sich eben nicht zum Ausdruck bringen können? So sieht man sie wenigstens.
Na ja, sehen tust du sie nicht. Ich sehe keine, also man sieht hübsche Bildchen von irgendwelchen Gestalten, das ist schon schlimm genug.
Ja ich meine jetzt richtig die Meinungen, meine ich.
Ja naja, na gut, was siehst du? Du siehst Text, du siehst Daten, du siehst aber nicht, was dahinter steckt. Ich kann dich im Internet ohne weiteres verarschen. Du weißt überhaupt nicht, mit wem du zu tun hast. Ich chatte mit dir und stelle mich dir als hübsche, junge, blonde, nette... Ja und du hast keine Chance. Und du hast keine Chance und ich mache mir deinen Spaß mit dir, das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Dann sehen wir Mail miteinander. Ich habe Angst vor den Leuten, die das total zerren Nutzen. Das war früher mal ein bisschen anders, ein bisschen mehr Verantwortung, ein bisschen mehr...
Es ist aber auch teurer geworden.
Und bunter.
Es ist auf alle Fälle bunter geworden. Aber ich gebe jetzt einfach mal einen Klick weiter.
Ja naja, ich habe im Prinzip auch Angst davor, dass das Internet zum Fernsehen abläuft.
Wer redet denn da eigentlich?
Also im Sinne von, dass eben dieses Medium zu einem Konsummedium verkommt und sich nicht als Kommunikationsmedium etabliert. Um das irgendwie mal zu erklären. Ich war in einer Podiumsdiskussion mit dem Thomas von RTL und der hat so angefangen, ja der Konsument, will der denn überhaupt das interaktive Fernsehen? Will der denn überhaupt Interaktivität? Der will doch Unterhaltung, der will doch dies und das. Und der Trick an der Diskussion war der, ich hab dann irgendwie versucht zu erklären, dass das Medium Fernsehen doch den Menschen von vorn an in so einer Rolle presst, wo im Prinzip voran nur noch irgendwie ausfielen kann, oder bestenfalls noch abschalten kann, aber eben gar nicht kommunizieren kann. Und dass das Internet als Medium oder der Computer eben noch ganz andere Möglichkeiten zumindest mal eröffnet. Und irgendwie, man kam, man konnte aber mit dem Mann nicht diskutieren, weil für den war Mensch so fest irgendwie übersetzt mit der Konsument, dass er gar nicht mehr auf die Idee kam, dass es vielleicht so etwas wie eine aktive Mediennutzung geben könnte. Also davor habe ich ein bisschen Angst, dass ich diese Leute sozusagen durchsetze.
Andy, du warst schon auf der CeBIT Home. Das ist dann ganz gezielt gerichtet auf den Konsumenten. Also da darf man sich dann angucken, wie bunt alles sein wird. Und da denke ich mal, das ist wahrscheinlich nichts anderes als eine riesen Werbeveranstaltung. Was war dein Eindruck? Wie sehen die Internet und Multimedia, um diese ganzen Schlagwörter mal in einen Topf zu werfen, Interessierten aus?
Wie sah da das Publikum aus? So wie wir hier. Es ist ein riesen Werbeshow, es ist also wahnsinnig laut. Jeder Stand versucht lauter als der andere zu sein. Es ist mitunter auch sehr bunt. Aber rein zu den Inhalten kommt man da schon wegen der Lautstärke nicht. Also das ist damit irgendwie auseinanderzusetzen. Die Computer-Bild ist rausgekommen und auf dem Niveau spielt sich das ab.
Aber Bau ist nicht drin?
Nein, Bau ist nicht drin. Aber wenn schon die Bild-Zeitung mit der Computer-Bild anfängt, dann wissen wir, es ist irgendwie das Ende noch.
Das ist übrigens genau das, was ich vorhin meinte. Übrigens mit den fertigen Haaren, ganz kurz, wir sitzen hier alle, haben fertige, lange Haare bis über die Schultern.
Wir sind alle picklig. Ich bin also gar nicht so picklig geworden.
So schlimm sahen sie ja gar nicht aus, aber es war halt irgendwie doch erstaunlich voll. Das hat mich ein bisschen überrascht, weil ich dachte immer, diese Konsumenten in der Anzahl gibt es gar nicht. Aber doch, alles voller Sauber und voller Begeisterung.
Alles Konsumenten.
Wir wollen jetzt erstmal hier im Chaos Radio von euch wissen, wovor ihr Angst habt. Also jetzt nicht im Allgemeinen, sondern speziell in Sachen Internet. Und wir haben auch wieder ein Voting. Das hatten wir in der letzten Show schon mal vor einem Monat. Und das hat sehr gut funktioniert. Und hat scheinbar nicht nur uns, sondern auch euch Spaß gemacht. Das heißt, wir haben verschiedene Telefonnummern, die ihr wählen müsst, um eine Frage zu beantworten. Das Ganze kostet euch nicht viel. Nämlich nur eine Einheit. Ist klar, geht ganz schnell. Die Nummer, sag ich schon mal, ist in Berlin 030 254492. 254492. Und dann müsst ihr eine Durchwahl wählen für die entsprechende Antwort. Und vielleicht sollten wir erstmal die Frage stellen. Die Frage lautet...
Tja, jetzt misst das du natürlich auf deinem Zettel.
Ich kann sie vorlesen, ich dachte, das kommt jetzt besser.
Warte mal, ich kann es nicht. Ich habe es auch noch.
Von wem Papiervermeidung. Was ist eigentlich die Frage? Was spielt ihr im Internet an, Meis?
Was habt ihr schon immer vermisst? Was ist die Killer Application? Es gibt Newsgroups, es gibt Mail, es gibt Kinderpornografie. Was wolltet ihr schon immer noch dazu haben?
Noch dazu?
Von den Sachen, die du gerade genannt hast, brauche ich nicht viel.
Ach, du brauchst nur Kinderpornografie. Kein schlechtes Schatzezimmer.
254492 ist die Nummer. Und dann, was fehlt dir am Internet am meisten? Jetzt kommt die Nummer, die ihr dann da hinten noch dran wählen müsst. Wenn ihr übers Internet einkaufen wollt. Wenn ihr Bundestagswahlen tätigen wollt.
Dann wählt ihr die 11.
Wenn ihr endlich HomeBanking machen wollt übers Internet.
Bleibt euch nur die 12.
Wenn ihr das Metaversum euch herbei wünscht.
Das Metaversum gibt es unter der 13.
CyberSex.
Gibt es unter der 14.
Wenn ihr die Delphi-Börse besuchen wollt.
Dann müsst ihr die 15 wählen.
Wenn ihr Wettbüros und Glücksspiele sucht.
Gibt es keine andere Wahl als 16.
Und wenn ihr am Internet endlich Blinde Kuh spielen wollt.
Das ist die 17, aber ich hab gerade überlegt, was Blinde Kuh eigentlich ist. Kann man das nochmal erklären?
Das ist die Alternative zu Plumpssack.
Es gibt dann auch Eierlaufen und Top-Schleif.
Die Reise nach Jerusalem.
Was fehlt euch im Internet am meisten? Die Telefonnummer in Berlin ist 25 44 92. Dann die 10 für Einkaufen, 11 für Wählen, 12 für HomeBanking, 13 für das Meta-Versum, 14 für CyberSex, 15 für die Delphi-Börse, 16 für Wettbüros und Glücksspiele und 17 für die blinde Kuh. Ansonsten könnt ihr euch hier einmischen unter der Nummer 0331 für Potsdam, 74 81 110. Und bei uns ist garantiert keine Anrufbeantworter dran, sondern Fritz mit dem Chaosradio.
Was ist eigentlich eine Delphi-Börse?
Was ist eigentlich Meta-Versum?
Was du behauptest, ist der Bundestag.
Ja, ihr seid unheimlich witzig, Blinde Kuh liegt vorne, das ist ganz klar. Der erste Anrufer, der hier durchkommt, darf dann mit uns über Radio Blinde Kuh stühlen. Wir haben euch gefragt, wovor habt ihr am meisten Angst im Internet und wir haben euch gleichzeitig gefragt, was fehlt euch im Internet am meisten. Ihr könnt uns hier anrufen, 0331 für Potsdam, 74 81 110. Das ist unsere Telefonnummer hier. Das gilt übrigens wie immer natürlich nicht nur für Leute, die das Internet benutzen, sondern auch für Leute, die das Internet nicht benutzen. Also zum Beispiel kann es ja auch sein, dass ihr am Montag losgeht und euch Focus kauft und den Spiegel kauft. Und in Focus ist irgendwie Titelseite Internet A bis Z im Stern, ist auch massig drin, zu Save It Home und so weiter. Und dass ihr davor sitzt und sagt, was wollen die eigentlich von mir? Was soll ich da? Was ist das? Dann könnt ihr hier natürlich auch anrufen und sagen, wovor ihr Befürchtungen habt. Und ihr könnt euch auch am Voting beteiligen. Da wählt ihr die Berliner Nummer 25 44 92. Und dann folgende Endziffern. Wir fragen euch, was fehlt euch im Internet am meisten? Ihr wählt dann hinten die 10 fürs Einkaufen, die 11 für Bundestagswahlen, die 12 für HomeBanking, die 13 für das Metaversum, die 14 für CyberSex, die 15 für Delphi-Börse, die 16 für Wettbüros und Glücksspiele und 17 für Blinde Kuh. Und hört auf bei Blinde Kuh anzurufen. Wir wissen genau, was ihr alle wirklich wollt. So, viel Zeit ist nicht mehr vor dem News, aber wir können schon mal gucken.
Ich weiß nicht, was mir im Internet so richtig fehlt. Das Einzige, was mich im Augenblick ziemlich nervt, ist, dass die Verbindungen alle ziemlich lernend sind.
Wo willst du dich ein?
Unterschiedlich.
Die ganzen freien Universitäten.
SNARF, freie Universität. An den Universitäten ist es natürlich auch schwierig, wo das Zeug nicht nur für wissenschaftliche Zwecke genutzt wird, sondern wo alle stundenlang an den Universitäten sitzen und sich einwählen, um was zu machen. Dass da eng ist, ist klar, weil die Ressourcen, die kostenlos zur Verfügung gestellt werden, zum Studieren, die werden wohl knapp.
Ich meine, wenn wir uns einwählen, das ist ja alles ziemlich schnell. Es wird dann erst langsam, wenn man weiter weggeht. Wenn man weiter weggeht, aus der Uni raus. Zu Uni hin haben wir gute Übertragungsverordnungen usw. Aber wenn man weiter weggeht, wird es langsam.
Das hängt auch ein Stück weit damit zusammen, dass einige doch meinen, das Fernsehen neu erfinden zu müssen. Und die effiziente Bandbreitenverschwendung mit hochauflösenden Grafiken und ähnlich wichtigen Dingen betreiben.
Außerdem wird das krasse Arbeit. Das wird immer alles besser. Next version will fix this. Wir kriegen ganz tolle Leitungen nach Amerika. Mit denen wird alles ganz toll, prima, schnell.
Aber richtig Angst macht ihr das doch nicht, dass alles mal langsamer wird, oder?
Und du hast die Ziele vor der Angst.
Was machst du denn am meisten am Internet? Also FTP, das heißt du holst dir irgendwelche Dateien für deinen Computer zu Hause?
Ja, um mein Betriebssystem ein bisschen aufzufrischen.
Was für ein Betriebssystem ist das?
Haben wir uns gedacht dann. Aber im Endeffekt läuft das nicht auf so eine Art Briefmarkensammeln hinaus?
Na ja, eigentlich schon, aber...
Was machst du denn mit deinem Computer zu Hause am meisten?
Böse bearbeiten, ein paar Mods anhören, ein paar Demos reinzählen, ein bisschen spielen.
Also eigentlich so hauptsächlich Entertainment?
Ja, Programmieren tue ich nicht mehr so viel, weil die meiste davon ist mir meistens bei Plakkencrash draufgegangen.
Aber irgendwie ist doch dann der Computer die neue Briefmarkensammlung oder die neue Modelleisenbahn?
Nee, das ist der neue Zeitverschwender. Bei Briefmarkensammlung, da hast du eine von ein paar wenigen, wenn du ganz toll bist, und bei Programm hast du eins von ganz vielen. Das ist nicht dasselbe, ne?
Da geht es dann wahrscheinlich mehr darum, dass man die meisten von den...
Da geht es darum, dass du es verstanden hast.
Oder dass du es verstanden hast, ja.
Was wenn? Seit wann machst du denn Internet?
Äh, mal überlegen. Ein bis zwei Jahre, glaube ich.
Und was hast du vorher gemacht?
Ähm, so hast du dich zu Hause mit meinem einzustehenden Rechner und freute mich darüber, weil ich Nullmodemkabel habe, dass ich ein paar Dateien zwischen zwei Rechnern in den Bewerb schicken konnte.
Also dein eigentliches Ziel besteht darin, Daten durch die Gegend zu schieben. Von A nach B und am besten auch noch von B nach A wieder zurück.
Ja, und halt auch zu chatten im Irg.
Und was ist da dein Lieblingskanal?
Entweder Berlin oder Linux, ja.
Aha, also auch dort beschäftigst du dich im Wesentlichen mit dem Selbstzweck Computer. Hast du schon mal Leute kennengelernt, die, sagen wir mal, nicht sich mit Linux beschäftigt haben, die du vielleicht sonst auf der Straße vielleicht getroffen hättest?
Ja, naja, ich hatte ein Erlang irgendwo mit irgendeiner geredet, Adressen aufgetauscht und so weiter und Frühkontakt hat ihr gestellt.
Ach, ganz normalen Briefkontakt?
Ja, ganz normalen Briefkontakt.
So mit Handschrei? Und habt ihr euch irgendwann mal getroffen?
Nö, also Erlang ist ein bisschen weit weg.
Man ist auch nicht so richtig auf den Erlang, das stimmt allerdings. Aber vielleicht kommt ihr dann mal in Berlin. Sven, ich danke dir erstmal und höre noch ein bisschen weiter zu.
Ja, mach ich.
Wissenswertes über Erlang, gleich Wissenswertes über die Welt im Fritz-Kurzinfo, erst mal ein bisschen Musik. Auch wir wissen, dass die C-Bit Home stattfindet, aber die findet in Hannover statt und wir finden in Berlin in Brandenburg statt. Und wir reden mit euch darüber, wofür ihr Angst habt in Sachen Internet. Und möchten gern von euch Erlebnisse hören. 0331 für Potsdam 74 81 110, ist euch schon mal beim Internet surfen irgendwas passiert, wo ihr gedacht habt, eiei, und so ein bisschen Schiss gekriegt habt oder gedacht habt, ist das jetzt wirklich gut, dann ruft uns an in Potsdam 74 81 110. Wir können auch noch über richtig tolle Erlebnisse im Internet reden, aber erstmal würde uns schon interessieren hier, was euch Angst macht, was euch Sorgen macht. Wir erklären euch gleich, was das Meter-Session ist. Und die Delphi-Börse.
Und die Opium-Zäppchen.
Und die Himmelkuh erklären wir euch auch. Aber erstmal reden wir mit... Stefan, war das der richtige Name? Hallo?
Hallo?
Christian war der richtige Name. Entschuldige, hi. Christian, wie ist mal was passiert, was dich ein bisschen hat zittern lassen?
Ja, da bin ich aus Versehen eigentlich, da hab ich ein bisschen rumgespielt mit dem TeleNet.
Knöpfchen drücken, ne?
Und habe dabei einen Rechner entdeckt, der offen war, praktisch. Also der über den Gast gekommen und offen war und der Gast hat ziemlich viele Rechte.
Wo war denn das? Im Internet, ja?
Das war an der Universität da. So, und der Rechner schien ziemlich wichtig zu sein und die hat nicht so den Plan gemacht über Sicherheit und so. Und hat noch mal geschrieben, ja Passwort ändern, wenn sie drin sind. Und naja, so typische Namen eingeben und kein Passwort. Ja, und dann hab ich so ein bisschen rumgespielt und ein bisschen rumgetüdelt im System. Ja, und dann, und dann hab ich gemerkt, dass der Ruth drin ist. Seit vier Minuten war der da drin und da hat er mich irgendwie angeschrieben. Und da ist mir ja doch schon der Herz ein bisschen runtergegangen. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nicht bei euch. Na ja, und da hat er mir halt angeschrieben, woher ich denn komme. Na ja, und dann ist er schnell ausgelockt, da hat er mich irgendwie zurückverfolgt. Und dann hat es meinen Vater abbekriegt.
War das der Account von deinem Vater oder was?
Ja, ja, das war zumindest die Stelle von meinem Vater, über die ich rausgegangen bin.
Also man muss das jetzt mal vielleicht, um das auch verständlich zu machen, was da passiert ist, an sich können natürlich Benutzer, also wenn meine Post zum Beispiel kann eigentlich, also eigentlich nur ich lesen, weil ich mich mit meinem Passwort einlogge auf einem Rechner. Und du bist auf diesen, du bist praktisch über den Namen eines anderen, in dessen Bereiche gestoßen, hast aber dann festgestellt, dass er unheimlich viel Rechte hat, also auch Zugriffsrechte auf andere Dateien. Und bist dabei allerdings ein paar Minuten lang beobachtet worden von dem sogenannten Super User, sage ich das jetzt richtig? Derjenige, der also diesen ganzen Rechner verwaltet und der natürlich als einziger Zugriff auf alle Dateien hat und der dann genau gucken kann, was ist, und der auch deine Spur zurückverfolgen kann. Was ist da weiter passiert?
Na, da gab es so ein bisschen Trara und mir sollte man den Uni-Account sperren. Und, also, das hat mein Vater gesagt, er sollte den besser schützen und blablabla. Und dann meinte er, da er die Gelder für diese Universitätsvergabe hat, hat er gesagt, das war mein Sicherheitsbeauftragter und er sollte das überprüfen. Damit war die Sache gegessen.
Was macht ihr jetzt dabei am meisten Angst, dass du erwischt worden bist? Oder dass das so leicht gehen kann?
Erst einmal, dass eine Universität mit solchen Rechnern einfach offen ist. Da wissen ich nicht, da könnten auch ganz andere Leute kommen.
Da kommen auch ganz andere Leute.
Die sind schon da.
Gab es gerade wieder eine schöne Geschichte. Aber erst eine anderthalb Stunde. Das darf ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Du bist schon soweit vorbereitet, Tim, dass du das Thema von innen eineinhalb Stunden weißt?
Ja, wir haben uns da dieses Mal vorgehalten.
Unglaublich, die Jungs, unglaublich. Sie werden immer besser. Wird bald umbenannt. Spießer Computer Club.
Du hast ja einen klassischen Hack gemacht. Ich nehme mal schwer an, dass es sich dabei um ein Unix-System gehandelt hat. Und die sind ja eigentlich bekannt dafür, dass sie immer irgendwelche schweren Wunden mit sich herumtragen, durch die Meinheit in das Herz hineinbohren kann. Von daher bieten sich diese Computer ja geradezu an.
Aber du musst erstmal einen Finder aufbauen.
Ja, eigentlich ist fast jeder offen, weil sie fast alle mit fehlerhafter Software bestückt sind. Und man muss halt nur diese Systeme kennen. Und das kann man aber das Internet schon teilweise recht einfach und verlässlich herausfinden. Was für Computersysteme, also ganz konkret, welche Betriebssysteme und Computermodelle es sich handelt. Und so werden Attacken gezielt gemacht. Interessant in dem Zusammenhang ist zum Beispiel eine alte Hapka-Geschichte mit dem Internetwurm. Das ist jetzt glaube ich schon auch schon wieder vier, fünf Jahre her. Das war das erste Mal, dass das Internet als solches überhaupt in den Medien groß erwähnt wurde. Gab es einen jungen Programmierer in Amerika, dessen Vater interessanterweise Sicherheitsbeauftragter war in den Messwerken. Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt den Namen nicht mehr.
Robert Morris war der, der das Ding geschrieben hat.
Dieses Programm ist ihm in gewisser Hinsicht entwischt. Das heißt noch während er es entwickelt hat und versucht hat es irgendwie auf ein Netzwerk anzuwenden.
Nein, nein, er hat es programmiert und hat aber übersehen, dass sich der Virus ungestört weiter... Er hatte ihn eigentlich schon fertig und hat ihn auch schon deswegen zu Testzwecken rausgejagt. Und dann ist er ein bisschen außerordnet.
Das meinte ich, genau, und dann setzt er sich halt in sämtliche Sun-Computer, die halt mit diesem Fehler ausgerüstet waren, irgendwie fort. Und das Ganze entwickelte dann vor allem eine Eigendynamik, die er dann schon gar nicht mehr kontrollieren konnte. Klassisches Problem und er ist natürlich dann auch in den Medien fett auseinandergenommen worden. Letztlich hat er sicherlich keinen Schaden, sondern nur einen guten Job davon getragen, wie das meistens so ist, aber das ist natürlich ein typischer Punkt. Vor allem weiß man ja nie genau, wann man nun schlimme Dinge auslöst auf irgendwelchen Computern.
Aber immerhin, ich bin überrascht, dass man doch sinnliche Erfahrungen machen kann, obwohl man von Computern sitzt. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, ein bisschen Adrenalin war da schon im Spiel, oder?
Christian, das war ja so...
Das ist vielleicht noch nicht so gut wie CyberSex, aber Adrenalin macht auch schon breit.
Das ist wahrscheinlich CyberSex, wenn ich mich frags.
Christian, was war denn so das Aufregendste, also das war natürlich auch aufregend, aber was war im positiven Sinne das Aufregendste, was du erlebt hast, oder das Nettes, oder das Beste, oder keine Ahnung?
War bestimmt das Gleiche.
Na ja, weiß ich nicht. Also wenn man denn... Ah nee, die ZDF, die war ich nicht.
Christian, du...
Hat nichts mit... Keine Angst... .pornografischen Sachen zu tun, sondern mit ein paar anderen Sachen, also...
Du, wir sind ganz unter uns, ganz einfach reden.
100.000.
100.000?
100.000? Wir haben das hier alles auf dem Bildschirm, wir wissen Bescheid.
Nee, nee, nee, also ich weiß gar nicht.
Momentan sind es... Jetzt sind es nur noch 14.
Du könntest ja sowas sagen, wie du kennst einen Freund, der...
Ich kenne einen Freund, der hat hier einen Freund und der Freund, der ist zum ersten Mal auf einem Illegalen Computer herausgekommen, wo sehr viel Software herum lag. Und dieser Freund, der hat mir davon berichtet.
Also Software, die eigentlich nicht so... Software, der eigentlich nicht so frei rumliegt.
Ja, also Windows NT zum Beispiel oder Windows 96.
Das war dann alles...
Windows 96?
Das war alles natürlich noch vor der... Nee, Windows 96, das kann doch irgendwie sein, dass das vor der Telekom Reform war, aber egal. Dann standen da einige Rechner die ganze Zeit online und haben Daten übertragen. Gut, da sind wir froh, dass du damit nichts zu tun hattest, Christian. Danke erstmal.
Ich danke Ihnen für dieses Gespräch.
Bis dann, ciao.
Interessanten Punkt, den da da angeschnitten hat.
Adrenalin?
Naja, die frei verfügbare Software im Netz. Es gibt massiv Orte im Netz, wo kommerzielle, also geschützte, copyrightgeschützte Software gezogen werden kann. Das sind in der Computerszene recht bekannte Orte. Ich denke, das ist auch so noch nicht mit thematisiert worden in Medien. Gerade im Windows-Bereich kriegt man wohl alles. Also da gibt es eigentlich nichts, was es nicht gibt. Und auch andere Plattformen sind weitaus abgedeckt. Das geht teilweise über diese oft der Kinderpornografie bezichteten Newsgroups. Aber das haben wir einen Mithörer?
Ja, wir haben einen Mithörer. Wer hustet schon, aber wer hat mich noch nicht angesprochen?
Doch, ja, ich versuchte es.
Sven, hi.
Nee, klar. Meine Modelleisenbahn wirklich nur über Computer steuern, wa?
Ja.
Sven, warte mal. Ja?
Dabei hätte das mit der Modelleisenbahn noch durchaus die Schilderung einer spannenden sinnlichen Erfahrung sein.
Das stimmt natürlich, ja.
Um die nachersinnlichen Erfahrungen.
Wollen wir mal schauen, was wir in den nächsten 2, 5 Stunden noch haben. Also man sollte die Modelleisenbahnindustrie nicht unterschätzen. Die Prisen seien die Skifahrer, sag ich nur.
So ist das hier. Da versucht man die ganze Zeit anzurufen, was übrigens totaler Quatsch war.
Jetzt dreh doch endlich mal die Mikros runter.
Nein.
Nein?
Und dann kommt man endlich durch, dann fliegt man gleich wieder raus. So unfair ist die Welt, aber es ist ein bisschen wie beim Anwähnen ins Internet. Und hier ist Chaos Radio, der Chaos Blue Moon. Wir fragen euch, was habt ihr im Internet erlebt, was euch Sorgen bereitet hat oder was euch erschrocken hat oder was euch sogar Angst gemacht hat. Andy hat gerade von sinnlichen Erlebnissen geredet. Auch darüber können wir reden. Also es gibt dann natürlich auch die Frage nach den positiven Erlebnissen. Erstmal interessiert uns aber eure Angst, eure Ängste. Und außerdem haben wir auch noch das Voting laufen. Ihr könnt euer Telefon auch noch benutzen. Man muss in diese Sendung anständig zuhören. Da brauchen wir ein Radio und drei Telefonleitungen. Da habe ich eine, um hier anzurufen, eine, um online zu sein und sich zum Beispiel die brandneue Chaosradio-Homepage anzugucken, deren URL wir später durchgeben, um es ein bisschen spannender zu machen. Und außerdem um sich am Voting zu beteiligen. Im Moment fragen wir euch, was fehlt euch im Internet am meisten? Ihr wählt die Berliner Rufnummer 254492. Und dann die 10, wenn euch das Einkaufen am meisten fehlt, die 11, wenn ihr über das Internet wählen wollt, die 12, wenn ihr eure Bankgeschäfte über das Internet abwickeln wollt. Ich hoffe, dass nicht irgendein Smartass anruft und sagt, das kann ich gar nicht an. Die 13, wenn ihr das Metaversum aufsuchen wollt.
Vielleicht müssen wir das aber echt erklären.
Ich lese erst mal zu Ende vor. Die 14, wenn ihr mehr CyberSex wollt, also Sex auch für die Leute, die sonst keinen bekommen. 15, das ist ein bisschen gemein, aber die 15 für die Delphi-Börse, die 16 für Wettbüros und Glücksspiele und die 17 für blinde Kuh. Im Moment liegt Einkaufen ganz weit vorne.
Können wir unseren Internet-Experten mal befragen, was das Metaversum ist?
Ja, genau. Was ist das Metaversum, Internet-Experte?
Und so muss ich nochmal sagen, alle Leute, die hier anrufen, sollen wirklich mal mit ihren Ängsten rausrücken. Wir wollen richtige Ängste haben, also ich jedenfalls. Ich will jetzt mal richtige Angst kriegen von den Leuten. Es geht nicht bloß, dass alle Leute irgendwelche Rassel kennen oder so.
Leugne nicht die Schweißperle auf deinem Kopf.
Genau.
So.
Das Metaversum.
Das Metaversum stammt als Begriff aus einem Buch, das ich leider nicht gelesen habe. Das ist ein Grundbuch in der Internetzene und ich hab nur davon gehört. Das ist aus dem Buch Snowcraft. Dort gibt es ein Virtual Reality Environment, in dem die ganze Welt nachgebaut ist. Korrigiert mich sofort, wenn ich irgendwas Pfeife sage.
Das ist nicht die ganze Welt, das ist nur eine Stadt, aber es ist beigeklemmend.
In dem Metaversum ist alles vorhanden und man kann sich das als so einen Ball, ist das so, auf ein Schreibtisch holen? Das ist so ein freischwedischer Ball über dem Schreibtisch.
Also soll ich dir jetzt mal erklären, welcher der Einzige das Buch gelesen hat?
Ich hab das Buch auch gelesen, aber mann gelesen.
Also im Snowcrush ist das so, dass das Internet, also das was wir jetzt als Internet kennen, eben das Metaversum ist und es wird mit so einem Projektor, was in deinem Laptop oder Computer eingebaut ist, so als Holografie um dich rumprojiziert. Also du siehst diese Sachen dreidimensional und kannst da auch durchsteuern und das ist dann eine Stadt. Das heißt, du hast eine Hauptstraße und alle, so wie du heute eine Adresse hast, weiß ich nicht, www.langnese.com oder de, hast du dann halt ein kleines Gebäude oder ein großes Gebäude, was Langnese ist und du gehst in dieses Gebäude rein. Im Endeffekt ist es aber nichts anderes, als diese Seite anzuwählen. Es ist alles einfach grafisch dargestellt. Und das interessante am Metaversum ist für mich in diesem Buch die Beschreibung der Avatarer, also der Darstellungen von Menschen, weil es nämlich so ist, dass die Leute, die keine Ahnung haben vom Programmieren, die haben alle so schwarz-weiß Figuren nur. Also es gibt Bestimmungen, dass zum Beispiel Leute nur eine bestimmte Höhe haben dürfen, weil sonst würden da riesen Monstern rumlaufen. Also die müssen sich an bestimmte Regeln halten, wenn sie sich selber im Netz darstellen wollen. Und die Leute, die keine Ahnung haben, sind halt nur so wie Fotokopien. Also so, die kann man fertig aus dem Netz ziehen, dann halt, weiß ich nicht...
Das ist sozusagen das Gegenstück zum Blink-Tag.
Genau, also das Default-Icon, genau. Und die sehen dann halt alle natürlich wunderschön aus. Und die Entwicklung, die da stattgefunden hat, und die finde ich eine sehr interessante Überlegung, ist, dass die Leute, die Ahnung haben und die programmieren können und sich selber zeichnen können oder was auch immer, die sehen möglichst so aus, wie sie wirklich aussehen. Also dann nicht mehr wunderschön und verheurisiert, sondern die versuchen, sich selbst möglichst naturgetreu im Netz darzustellen. Das finde ich eine ganz interessante Überlegung eigentlich. Wird das so sein?
Das wird so sein. Davon abgesehen, dass diese holographische Projektion, das ist ein bisschen weit hergeholt, aber an holographischen Displays wird aber gearbeitet.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass das so sein wird. Ich glaube, es wird schon ein Auseinanderdruck geben zwischen virtueller Welt und wirklicher Welt sozusagen. Also dass es schon eine Menge Leute geben wird, die werden kleine grüne Monster jagen oder Doom spielen oder irgendwie einen Quatsch machen.
Ja, aber wo werden sie das tun?
Sie werden das vor ihrem blöden Computer tun in ihrer blöden Stube.
Nein, ich meine, in welcher virtuellen Welt? Die wird natürlich irgendwas sein, was sie kennen. Weil für was anderes braucht man Fantasie.
Wir haben doch schon eine virtuelle Welt, heißt Fernsehen.
Ja, aber da kann man nicht...
Wir haben auch noch eine andere virtuelle Welt, die heißt Bundestag. Ich meine, es gibt eine Menge virtueller Welten. Das ist irgendwie nicht die Frage. Die Frage ist, wie kompatibel diese Räume sind. Ob das sozusagen auseinanderdriftet, dass die Leute sich vor dem Internetterminal in die virtuelle Welt hineinbegeben, sich dort erfreuen und quicken und wenn sie nach draußen gehen, kriegen sie keine Luft mehr zum Atmen, weil blöderweise haben sie irgendwie vergessen...
Auf jeden Fall, wenn ihr das Meta-Version wollt, wenn es das ist, wo ihr euch schon immer nachgesehen habt, dann müsst ihr die 13 wählen.
Nach der 25, 44, 92.
Eigentlich echt Plumsack.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal zu Ende erklären, da haben wir nämlich noch was anderes.
Vielleicht kann CyberSex mal jemand erklären.
CyberSex kann man eine gute Sache ausführen. Ah, der Internet-Experte, alles klar. Ah, dann fänden wir was ein. Vielleicht sollten wir sowieso... Gab es nicht mal die Idee, hier eine Buchkritikrubrik einzuführen? Über CyberSex gibt es kein Buch, das ich empfehlen möchte. Aber zu CyberSex fällt mir ein anderes Buch ein. Das ist das Dilbert-Prinzip. Dort steht der Unterschied in sexueller Hinsicht zwischen Star Trek-Ingenieuren und normalen Ingenieuren in Companies da. Star Trek-Ingenieure haben Reisen durchs Universum und Sex mit lauter fremden Lebensformen, wohingegen normalerweise Ingenieure sich vor dem Universum verstecken und Sex ohne Beteiligung von fremden Lebensformen haben.
Das ist präzise ausgedrückt. Gibt es irgendjemand, der Visionen über CyberSex hat? Visionen? Ja, ich meine, also Chat und so weiter.
Also ich denke, dass das mit Außerirdischen auch echt spannend ist.
Echt?
Also ich kenne eine Form des CyberSex schon recht gut. Die Frage ist, ob Andy jetzt so schnell wie möglich an sein Handy rangehen kann.
Ich mache mal dein Mikro aus, Andy.
Es ist schwierig, ob man das schon CyberSex nennen darf. Aber Telefonsex, sprich sexuelle Interaktionen auf sprachlicher Basis, hat schon so viel von dem Sex, den wir jetzt kennen, genommen, dass man schon von einer Art CyberSex sprechen kann. Zumal wenn die Systeme so gut sind, dass man nicht mehr weiß, ob an der anderen Seite nun wirklich ein Mensch ist oder eine Maschine. Wir haben gestern gerade gemeinschaftlich ein neues Spracherkennungssystem, was allerdings für etwas völlig anderes verwendet wurde, gemeinsam uns angehört und waren alle schwer beeindruckt, wie gut das funktioniert hat und wie gut es auf bestimmte Phrasen reagiert hat, die man gesagt hat, sodass es also nicht weit entfernt ist, bis man eben auch diese ganzen animierten, noch mit echten Personen animierten Sex-Chat-Kanäle automatisiert hat. Darum geht es eigentlich jetzt nicht. CyberSex ist grundsätzlich zunächst einmal sexuelle Interaktion über virtuelle Kanäle. Und da gehört Telefon definitiv dazu, wenn ein Computer dahinter ist.
Sex ist die Kommunikation auf einem Ebenen.
Das ist das Problem, dass die Leute sehr unterschiedliche Vorstellungen davon haben, was Sex ist.
Deswegen ist das nicht so viel. Ich habe eine ziemlich intellektuelle Vorstellung. Viel mehr auf viel tieferen Ebenen.
Dann machen wir doch mal, was ist denn Sex für dich?
Ja je, CyberSex ist nicht für mich.
Der Internet-Experte hat wahrscheinlich keinen Sex.
Nehmen wir doch einfach mal an, dass wir alle eine konkrete Vorstellung davon haben, was Sex ist, unabhängig davon, ob sie nun gleich sind.
Du hast bloß nicht Begriffe definiert.
Wieso bin ich total verklemmt?
Ich versuche, CyberSex zu adressieren.
Moment mal, die Telefonnummer von diesem hübschen Spracherkennungssystem.
Nein, du wirst halt keine Ahnung für machen.
Es ist doch kein Verbrechen, mal zu versuchen, die Begriffe, mit denen wir hier hantieren, zu definieren.
Ich versuche das doch die ganze Zeit. Lass mich doch mal ausgehen. Ich habe halt schon diese Erfahrung gemacht und ich muss feststellen, CyberSex-Erfahrung, Nein, ich rede von CyberSex. Und zwar von dem CyberSex, diesem First Stage CyberSex, der sich eben über Telefonen abspielt und der eben auch weitgehend bereits computergestützt ist. Und wer mal auf so einer Sexparty da angerufen hat, der weiß, dass irgendwie die meistgesagten Phrasen, das erste ist Hallo.
Alle sagen halt die ganze Zeit Hallo, Hallo.
Ist das wie eine Kneipe? Ja, pass auf.
Und dann würden halt alle sofort wieder... Und da gehen dann schon wieder mindestens zehn Einheiten drauf bei den Anrufern, und zwar mal zehn, weil sie sich halt jetzt alle irgendwie was ausrechnen. Und das ist das, was sie als Sex in dem Moment empfinden. Das ist das, was für sie kybernetisch ist. Denn er hat für sie eine Hemmschwelle, die sie im richtigen Leben erfahren haben.
Na ja, nur, dass sie in die ganz richtige Handbewegung gemacht, als du gesagt hast, das ist, was sie für Sex verfinden.
Also Moment, aber ich finde... Nein, ich hab jetzt da noch eine Gegenfrage, weil ich finde die Hemmschwelle viel, viel höher. Ich finde die Hemmschwelle viel höher in so einem Stimmensystem anzurufen und da mich mit Leuten zu unterhalten, von denen ich keine Ahnung habe.
Was heißt denn hier Hemmschwelle? Ich meine, wenn du eine Hemmschwelle zum Reden hast, dann ist das eine Sache, aber mit Sex hat das, Entschuldigung, eigentlich mal nichts.
Johnny, wir sind jetzt ganz allein und keiner hört uns zu. Kannst du mal dein rotes Leibchen ausziehen?
Ich hab kein rotes Leibchen.
Du hast es schon ausgezogen.
Achso, ich muss sagen, dass ich ein rotes Leibchen habe. Na gut, aber was wir natürlich meinen mit was fehlt euch im Internet am meisten, ist natürlich CyberSpex.
CyberSpex.
Lass uns lieber die Delphi-Phase erklären, das hat alles keinen Sinn.
Also Leute, wenn ihr das wirklich wollt, dann wählt die 2, 5, 4, 4, 9, 2 und die 14.
Und wenn ihr definieren wollt, was ihr wollt, dann sagt doch mal die Nummer von hier an.
03312, 748110. Und da ist auch schon jemand, der uns jetzt CyberSex erklärt. Hallo. Genau so sieht CyberSex aus.
So, das war schön. Mach doch mal das Mikro auch schön. War ich gut?
Hat's dir genauso gefallen wie mir, Zenn? Ganz interessant ist ja, nachdem wir das Metaversum erklärt haben, hat das Metaversum im Televoting hier im Chaos Radio tierisch aufgeholt.
Da müssen wir jetzt unbedingt die Delphi-Börse nachlegen.
Ja, was meinst du, was los ist, wenn wir erklären, was CyberSpex bedeutet?
Na ja, mit CyberSex hat er nicht richtig gegriffen oder hat das aufgeholt.
Ich hab das jetzt CyberSpex getauft. Ihr könnt anrufen beim Voting, ihr könnt auch hier anrufen. 0331 für Potsdam 74 81 110 ist die Nummer des Chaosradios. Obwohl wir gerade im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes etwas abgeglitten sind, reden wir eigentlich über eure Ängste in Bezug auf das Internet. Wenn ihr schon mal irgendwas erlebt habt beim Surfen, wo ihr ein bisschen Schreck gekriegt habt oder wo ihr Angst bekommen habt, oder wenn einfach die Vision an bestimmte Dinge euch Angst bereitet, dann ruft uns an und dann 0331 für Potsdam 74 81 110. Ich hab letztens bei soviel geredet und viel geschrieben in Zeitungen über Nazis im Internet und so weiter, wovon ich relativ wenig mitkriege als regulärer Benutzer. Da hab ich mich auf die Suche begeben und habe Seiten gefunden, die sich um solche Sachen kümmern. Natürlich findet man die. Das erschrickt schon. Dafür hab ich keine Angst, sondern ich finde es okay, dass ich mir das auch mal in Ruhe angucken kann, unerkannt sozusagen, um einfach sich zu informieren. Aber das ist schon ein bisschen erschreckend, was da so abgeht. Einfach die pseudowissenschaftlichen Statements, die finde ich doch sehr, sehr hart.
Auf der anderen Seite erschreckt einen doch glaube ich auch sehr die Tatsache, dass das einfach tatsächlich der Fall ist. Dass es diese Leute, mit denen man sich auseinandersetzen muss, eher gut, dass die im Internet sind.
Das ist völlig meine Meinung. Also ich finde es klasse, dass ich gucken kann, wie denken diese Leute eigentlich und was schreiben die auf und was für eine Einstellung haben die.
Sag mal, wie kommst du jetzt von CyberSex auf Nazis? Also der Sprung, Entschuldigung, den habe ich jetzt nicht mitmachen können.
Die Brücke hast du gerade geschlagen. Ich habe versucht, den Leuten klar zu machen, was ich meine, mit Angst haben vor bestimmten Sachen.
Aber ich hoffe doch, dass Sex keine Angst macht, sondern ein Spass.
Ich habe überhaupt nicht Sex und Nazis in Verbindung gebracht.
Ach so, das war ich also.
Lass uns mal die Delphi-Börse an.
Lass uns die Musik hören.
Wollen wir unseren Internet-Experten nur fragen, zur Delphi-Börse?
Ohje, das ist schon wieder so ein Buch, das ich vor so langer Zeit gelesen habe.
Wir haben einen Anrufer.
Ist das schon wieder ein Buch?
Schon wieder ein Anrufer. Hallo, Anrufer.
Denk uns mal ab.
Ja, hallo.
Hi, wer bist denn du?
Hallo.
Hallo, wer bist du denn?
Alle, die gerade am Telefon sind.
Hast du Angst deinen Namen zu sagen?
Hallo?
Hat er schon was gesagt, oder?
Er hat hallo gesagt. Alle, die hier gerade angerufen haben.
Wir müssen erst so Chatlinemäßig machen. Hallo?
Irgendwelche Frauen hier?
Hallo?
Mach doch mal Musik.
Ich komme aus dem Rheinland.
Hallo?
Hallo? Kann mich jemand hören?
Ach komm, Johnny, lass gut sein. Dreh die Musik auf.
Also ehrlich, ich würde hier auch nicht anrufen.
Ich verstehe das nicht, dass die Leute anrufen und dann wieder auflegen. Ich versuche es nochmal.
Hallo?
Super.
Der hält uns für einen Anrufbeantworter. Stimmt ja auch.
Hallo? Ach, dann nicht. Ich versuche es nochmal. Hallo? Oh, ein Mensch. Hallo. Wie geht's? Wer bist du denn?
Ich bin der Axel.
Axel, hast du irgendwelche Ängste?
Ja, ich wollte erst mal was sagen, weil ich finde, ihr solltet erst mal ein bisschen Respekt vor euren Gehörern haben, weil ich finde das einfach eine Frechheit. Ich bin nämlich 15, hab Pickel und, naja, das ist kein Verbrechen. ich sitz halt den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner und ihr reißt da so Witze und so.
Ich hab auch Pickel, ich sitz auch den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner.
Ich sitz den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner, aber ich hab keine Pickel.
Es geht doch einfach mal darum, dieses Klischee irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, durch Überdeutlichkeit.
Ich bin 28, ich hab immer noch Pickel, mach dir keine Hoffnung.
Aber jetzt deine Ängste, Axel.
Na, erstens, ich hab Angst vor diesen ganzen Laymen, die halt überhaupt keinen Plan haben, an das was sie schreiben. Zum Beispiel in diesen ganzen Zeitungen halt Badies und Pornografie. Also sagen wir mal, das macht jetzt im Durchschnitt 50% des Netzes aus.
Ne, ne, aber ich weiß schon, was du meinst mit Pickel und Pickel.
Ja, weil ich so halte, die spielen da so hoch und sind auch viele andere Sachen auf dem Netz los.
Was machst du? Du bist Internet-User.
Ja, sagen wir mal eher Surfer und ich find's interessant, weil du kannst halt mit vielen Leuten kommunizieren und so.
Hast du das dann schon mal erlebt, dass du jemanden kennengelernt hast und den dann auch im echten Leben getroffen hast?
Ne, in Mailboxen höchstens, aber auf dem Netz noch nicht, ne. Dafür benutze ich es aber auch zu unregelmäßig. Ich benutze es halt, ich mach 3D-Grafik, Computer-Animation und für mich ist das Netz halt eine schöne Möglichkeit, meine Sachen mehreren Leuten zugänglich zu machen, vielen Leuten und mit denen zu kommunizieren, Austausch zu haben und aktiv was zu machen. Ja, das ist unter www.mindlabs.com Mindlabs? M-I-N-D-L-A-B-S. Die Seite ist jetzt aber endlich. Ich hab sie geschafft nach drei Tagen online, also erst seit drei Tagen. Und es steht zwar nicht da, aber leider noch im Aufbau, weil es sind halt ziemlich ein paar Grafiken da und ich hab sie im Blog abgespeichert statt jedes Einzelnen und dadurch sind die Datezeiten oberst lange und das ist ziemlich essen.
Das ist okay, wir kennen das Problem, dass das doch viel Arbeit macht.
Macht dir denn nun irgendetwas konkret Angst? Ich meine, was du toll findest, haben wir schon gehört.
Na, wo ich mal einen schönen Adrenalin-Schuss hatte, ist, als ich ein paar Hackerseiten besucht haben, was doch recht selten ist, also diese Underground-Gruppen oder sonst was. Da muss man halt ein bisschen suchen. Und der Typ, der die Seite gemacht hat, hat halt bemerkt, dass ich einen Java-Boser benutze. Und hatte dann unten auch, also der hatte schon richtig Ahnung und da kam dann unten auch als Rolltext, na, wie ist denn dein Boser so und was hältst du davon, dass ich jetzt gleich deine Plattform mitnehmen könnte, weil das geht ja. Das ist schon machbar und...
Du meinst nicht, dass das vielleicht ein HTML eingefügter Satz war, der unten auf jeden Fall durchlauft, wenn du die Seite angehst?
Ja, also in diesem Fall war es so, weil das ist ein Fall zur Verteidigung der Hacker oder was weiß ich, zur Unterstützung oder sowas. Also die werden sich da sicherlich sowas nicht erlauben, aber die Theorie ist halt, dass es geht. Ich finde, man sollte halt diese kriminelle Energie gegen halt die negativen Seiten eben des Internets benutzen, wie zum Beispiel halt diese Nazi-Sites oder Kinderpornografie. Also die kann man ja auch relativ schnell hochziehen lassen sozusagen.
Ich finde es so ein Negativ, Nazis und Kinderpornografie.
Naja, wie ihr gesagt habt, es ist in Ordnung, dass man sich da informieren kann, sehen kann, wie die Leute denken, was sie so machen. Da vielleicht noch, aber für Kinderpornografie habe ich kein Verständnis.
Hast du denn schon mal eine Website gesehen, wo so Kinderpornografie gezeigt wurde?
Ich bin über Umwege mal rangekommen, ja.
Also ich habe selber meinen ganzen Tag damit verbracht, nach Kinderpornografie Website zu suchen. Ich habe keine einzige gefunden. Die einzigen Seiten, die ich gefunden habe...
Ja, habe ich gemacht.
Also ich meine, sicherlich gibt es die auch, nur sind die natürlich in dem Sinne nicht wirklich öffentlich.
Das ist ja etwas, was man bemerkt.
Die Nazis sehen das allerdings ganz anders. Auf der anderen Seite ist es eben so, dass Dinge dadurch, dass sie nun öffentlich gemacht werden, jeder Kram wird im Internet öffentlich gemacht und dadurch übernimmt auch nicht gleich die Weltregierung. Die Nazis sind halt unterferner liefen. Wir haben mittlerweile mehrere hundert, noch teilweise sehr viele kritische Resekte, weil sie nicht so bekannt in ihren Auswirkungen sind. Ich will jetzt mal keine Worte in den Mund nehmen.
Ich denke aber, im Bereich Kinderpornografie geht es auch nicht darum, also da darf man natürlich auch nicht so klingen, als ob man, und das tun wir hier auch nicht, aber als ob man dafür harmlosen will. Natürlich ist das ein Bruchteil von dem, was stattfindet im Internet. Aber da geht es natürlich auch nicht um die Vertriebswege. Das wäre, als ob man jetzt, also wenn unsere Familienministerin bei neuen Kinderpornos-Skandalen gleich ruft, wir müssen im Internet Kinderpornos verbieten, dann ist das, als ob man Videorekorder verbieten will, sondern da geht es natürlich, das eigentliche Problem liegt ganz woanders. Also ich wollte das nur noch mal dazu sagen, nicht, dass jetzt jemand anruft und sagt, ne, ne, ne.
Vor allem das Problem bei dieser Thematisierung mit Kinderpornografie ist, dass alle Leute glauben, die sich jetzt über Kinderpornos unterhalten auf dem Internet, wären halt automatisch auch entsprechend gefährliche Leute. Nicht selten handelt es sich dabei aber um kranke Menschen, also nicht über Leute, die einfach da, also nicht nur krank im Sinne von, dass sie gleich loslaufen, alle Leute umbringen, sondern die einfach ein Problem haben und das Internet nutzen, um sich auszutauschen mit anderen Leuten, die das gleiche Problem haben. Aber solche Newsgroups werden eben auch gesperrt, die eben eine soziale Diskussion darüber führen. Und das ist das Problem mit diesem Hype.
Mit diesem Hype. Axel, ich danke dir erstmal für schöne Animationen im Netz. Rote Coloise-Schachtel, die sich dreht. Ja, wir haben das gerade hier und es sieht ziemlich klasse aus.
Schreibt mir doch mal eine Mail, dass da sich vielleicht, falls ihr mal Grafik braucht oder falls jemand mal eine Adresse hat.
Ich bin interessiert, halt aktive Sachen zu machen.
Ich sag auch gleich nochmal die Adresse an, dass sich das Leute, die sich jetzt dafür interessieren, auch mal angucken können.
Okay, schön.
Ein anderes Problem.
Ich glaube, leider kann man im Moment keine Mail schreiben.
Das wird sich in der Woche geregelt haben.
Okay, dann sollen die Leute erst mal gucken und dann ab und zu probieren.
Alles klar.
Bis dann. Ciao. Also das sieht wirklich klasse aus. Könnt ihr jetzt von da nicht sehen, aber ich kann es sehen. Schachtel, die sich hier dreht und so ein paar Zigaretten qualmen. Richtig nett. Wer sich angucken will, was Axel macht, in 3D-Animationen, der kann das tun unter www.mindlabs.com/axel. Und so langsam geht das gar nicht. Unsere Sachen hier sind auch ziemlich lahm, aber haben es schon auf dem Bildschirm. Gucken wir von zu Hause noch mal in Ruhe an. Axel, und wenn wir hier für die Radiosendung ein paar 3D-Animationen brauchen, dann sagen wir natürlich Bescheid.
Die Delphi-Börse.
Ok, dann erklär jetzt erstmal die Delphi-Börse. Raus aus der schönen Musik. Delphi-Börse, was ist die Delphi-Börse?
Ich wollte, dass die erklärt wird.
Du hast gesagt, du erklärst die jetzt.
Also das Buch, aus dem du da standest, ist der Schockwellenreiter. Wer das Buch gelesen hat, wer weiß es, wer weiß es.
Ja, ich hab's auch gelesen. Also die Delphi-Börse ist sozusagen, jeder kann eine Wette einbringen kann. Also auf ein Ereignis, was irgendwie stattfinden könnte, eine, ja, die sozusagen zur Wette steht. Also was, dass ich das zum Beispiel Bill Clinton irgendwie beim Haschischrauchen auf der Toilette im Weißen Haus erwischt wird. Und dann kann eben jeder dafür oder dagegen wetten, irgendwie, dass das passiert oder nicht. Und der Trick ist ja, dass natürlich nicht nur so absurde Ereignisse, die niemals stattfinden könnten, wie eben die erwähnende Geschichte mit Bill Clinton dort verwettet werden, sondern auch durchaus Sachen, die im Bereich des Möglichen sind. Und es gibt inzwischen ja so Graubereiche der Wissenschaft wie Trendforschung und was weiß ich, Nachrichtenjournalisten oder so ähnliche Propheten. Und die benutzen diese Daily Person also tatsächlich ein Stück weit, um Wirklichkeit zu erforschen. Weil wenn unheimlich viele Leute der Meinung sind, dass ein bestimmtes Ereignis eintreffen wird, dann ist das schon relativ wahrscheinlich.
Also im Prinzip sprechen wir hier von etwas, was es schon gibt. Das Prinzip ist ja bereits realisiert worden im Internet. Es heißt Idea Futures. Filmiert soweit ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr unter diesem Namen. Das geht jetzt gerade in irgend auch was mit Future, irgendeinen anderen kommerziellen Dienst über. Die Idee ist also im Prinzip schon aufgekauft worden und wird so auch im Internet bereits betrieben. Wenn es euch also im Internet gefehlt hat, dann könnt ihr es im Prinzip schon aufsuchen. Jetzt leider gerade keine URL zur Hand. Und wenn ihr das aber auch schon immer haben wolltet, dann müsst ihr wählen die 15.
Und ich sage jetzt auch noch mal alle Nummern. Wir haben nicht nur unsere Telefonnummer hier, nämlich die 03312 Potsdam 7413, 748110, sondern wir haben auch einen Fritz Chaosradio Voting geschaltet. Ihr wählt die Berliner Nummer 254492. Und dann folgen der Endziffern. Wir fragen euch, was fehlt euch im Internet am meisten? Wenn euch das Einkaufen fehlt, dann wählt die 10 hinten. Wenn euch die Bundestagswahlen fehlen, dann wählt die 11. Wenn ihr HomeBanking wollt, dann wählt die 12. Wenn euch das Metaversum fehlt, haben wir von erklärt, dann wählt die 13. Wenn euch CyberSex anmacht, dann wählt die 14. Wenn ihr die eben beschriebene Delphi-Börse wollt, dann wählt die 15. Wenn ihr Wettbüros und Glücksspiele wollt, online, dann wählt die 16. Und wenn ihr unbedingt Blinde Kuh spielen wollt, dann wählt die 17. Übrigens alle Anrufer bei Blinde Kuh werden registriert und gleich von uns zurückgerufen. Um das mal ein bisschen einzudämmen hier. Interessant ist übrigens, dass erst nachdem wir jetzt die Delphi-Börse erklärt haben, die 15 überhaupt gewählt wird, vielleicht hätten wir das doch am Anfang erklärt.
Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal HomeBanking erklären.
HomeBanking ist so, dass wir praktisch von eurem Konto Geld auf unseres überweisen können.
Genau.
Übers Internet.
Bundestagswahlen können wir dann auch gleich nochmal erklären, dass die Politiker von eurem Konto sich Geld überweisen können.
Hallo Fede, hallo Fede, na?
Wieso hast du denn nicht mitgekommen?
Ich gucke erstmal noch, ob es hier Ängste gibt. Hi, hier ist ChaosRadio, wer ist da?
Ich bin Philipp. Hallo, ja, ich wollte eigentlich was sagen, dass ich eigentlich Angst davor habe, dass sie hatten Leute, die sich vom Internet einen Haufen versprechen, so bunte Bildchen wie Fernsehen, und das Internet stürmen und das völlig überfüllen.
Das heißt, dass sozusagen nichts mehr geht, weil alle es wollen?
Ja, genau.
Was machst du, wie lange bist du online?
Ich finde jetzt, wie lange, anderthalb Jahre ungefähr.
Und wofür nutzt du das Internet hauptsächlich?
Hauptsächlich ein paar Dateien, also hauptsächlich Musik und so, weil ich mit dem Computer ein bisschen Musik mache und womit ist alles drunter.
Du bist also einer der viel zitierten Internetmusiker, wo immer auch viel gerne geschrieben wird. Also sowieso ist ja diese unglaubliche Diskrepanz zwischen dem, was in den Medien steht, hauptsächlich Printmedien und dem, was tatsächlich stattfindet, sehr auffällig. Du bist also tatsächlich einer, der sich mit irgendjemand anders, was tauscht du aus, Mediafiles oder wirklich Sounds?
Ja, beides.
Und du machst selber Musik und mit wem hast du da Kontakt, mit wem du dich austauschst?
Ja, mit irgendwelchen Leuten in Newsgroups und den Leuten, die da ihre Homebanks haben und die ganzen Sounds anbieten, wo ich die mir alle runterhole.
Okay, und du hast Sorge, dass die Leute, die, weiß ich nicht, noch keinen konkreten Grund eigentlich haben, ins Internet zu gehen, dass die so viel von der Bandbreite wegnehmen, dass du das nicht mehr machen kannst? Hast du da gemerkt, dass es in letzter Zeit schon langsamer geworden ist?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Es wurde immer langsamer und langsamer und...
Aber sind nicht auch neue Dinge hinzugekommen, die dich interessieren? Schon. Mehr Daten, mehr Treffik. Ich denke gar nicht mal, dass das Internet langsamer wird, sondern ich denke, dass wir derzeit nur gerade einen kleinen Pillenknick haben. Weil nicht, dass so viele Leute jetzt auf einmal dazukommen, aber die ganzen Telekommunikationsfirmen nicht wirklich darauf vorbereitet sind. Das ist wahrscheinlich, Bandbreite ist wahrscheinlich in zwei Jahren alles gar kein Thema mehr. Beschäftigst du dich denn mit dem Internet auch in der Form, dass du einfach mal schaust, wie die Internetkultur selber ist, also dich über bestimmte Dinge informierst, was du vielleicht vorher nicht getan hast?
Also rumsorgen und rumgucken, was es so gibt und so.
Begreifst du das Internet als Bewusstseinserweiterung oder eher nicht?
Oh Gott, als Bewusstseinserweiterung? Na eher als ein Lieferant von mehr Informationen, als man so kriegen würde halt.
Aber auch als man mehr verkraften kann, oder? Also ich weiß nicht mehr, geht das so, dass ich schon gerne auch mal rumgucke, was es so alles gibt und spezielle Newsclubs sind ja dafür großartig. Allein dieses Durchscrollen durch die Liste, da kann man nur den Kopf schütteln. Das ist natürlich auch spannend, aber an sich schießt man sich doch irgendwann wieder auf die Themen ein, auf die zwei, drei, mit denen man sich beschäftigt und die einen interessieren, oder? Das war, siehst du, ich bin ein scheiß Interviewer, so darf man keine Fragen stellen. Ich liefere den Satz und du sagst nur noch, ja das ist blöd.
Wie mehrere Hörer-Interviere. Genau, ihr wartet mal mit, ja oder?
Wir haben jetzt multiple Choices.
Jetzt habe ich deinen Namen vergessen. Philipp. Wenn du sagst, du machst Musik, gibt es denn auch bei dir eine Adresse, wo man sich Soundfiles von dir, oder MIDI-Files, oder was auch immer, irgendwas, was du kreierst, anhören kann?
Nee, die gibt es nicht.
Hast du sowas mal vor an der Homepage zu machen, zu sagen, hier ist meine Musik, hörst du euch an? Und sind wir aber da nicht an dem wirklich interessanten Punkt, der das Netz sein kann, dass du zum Beispiel, weiß ich nicht, du sitzt zu Hause und Synthesizer, oder das ganze Media-Equipment kostet ja nicht mehr so viel, wie es alles mal gekostet hat, und kannst im Endeffekt deine Musik der gesamten Welt zur Verfügung stellen, ohne dass du eine Plattenfirma und einen Vertrieb brauchst?
Wenn man seine Zeug anbieten kann, ohne irgendwann irgendeinen dritten oder zweiten einzuspannen, dann müsste man doch noch was zu essen haben.
Es gibt bereits Internet-Labels, das ist dir bekannt? Und dann bist du das HomeBanking? Hast du bei unserem Telefonaufruf teilgenommen?
Weil?
Ja, weil ich erstmal Wettnummer angerufen habe.
Weil nicht alle haben fünf Telefone.
Du brauchst nicht mehr anzurufen, wenn du uns sagst, welches von den sieben, von den acht Möglichkeiten dir am meisten zuspricht. Was fehlt dir denn am meisten?
Ich kann es dir nochmal vorlesen. Was fehlt dir im Internet am meisten? Einkaufen, Bundestagswahlen, HomeBanking, das Metaversum, CyberSex, Stealthy-Börse, Wettbüros und Glücksspiele oder Blinde Kuh?
Ich glaube das Metaversum.
Hast du das Buch gelesen?
Nee, habe ich nicht. Aber so wie ihr das erklärt habt, hört sich das sehr interessant an.
Also die Idee, dass du ins Internet gehst und alles grafisch ist, und du dann zum Beispiel in einen Musikladen reingehst und da deine Dateien lässt, die fasziniert sich schon.
Ja, es wäre um einiges interessanter, schätze ich mal. Aber dazu würden auch die Übertragungsbreiten nicht herhauen im Moment.
Nein, im Moment sicherlich nicht.
Also ich glaube das Ideale wäre Blinde Kuh im Metaversum.
Macht ihr das keine Angst irgendwie, die Tatsache? Nehmen wir mal dieses Bandbreitenproblem. Sagen wir mal, das ist jetzt einfach gelöst. Tim kommt und sagt irgendwie, das ist gelöst und morgen kann es losgehen. Jetzt stellt mal vor, jeder surft zuhause nicht nur von einer Seite zum nächsten. Und alles ist Hypertech, sondern alles ist einfach 3D.
Ja, das wäre eben wie im Leben nur halt mit beamen können. Ich mache Schnuck und bin da. Das ist ja toll. Einmal raufgeklickt und zack.
Aber du bist ja nicht wirklich da.
Es fühlt sich nicht so an. Das ist ein Unterschied.
Also Angst macht dir der Gedanke nicht?
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das dann irgendwann genau irgendwie gegenläufige Entwägungen gibt, dass die Leute...
Ja, das ist dann eher vom Leben Angst.
Ja, oder dass die Leute alle eher irgendwie sich sinnlös ihre Erfahrungen so und sich dann irgendwie anfangen zu verprügeln oder Sex miteinander zu haben oder was weiß ich was. Einfach weil irgendwie das Internet zum Vakuum erzeugt.
Aber macht ihr das nicht Angst, dass Leute davor Angst haben könnten, da wieder rauszukommen?
Ich glaube, ich habe Angst vor blöden Fragen, aber...
Das hast du einfach nicht kapiert, Andi. Ich meine, was mich interessiert, also es macht mir schon ein bisschen Angst, dass Leute das toller finden als die Realität, weil es einfacher ist und dann nicht mehr rauskommen darf.
Das finde ich aber relativ verständlich. Ich glaube, wenn wir jetzt die Frage stellen würden, was macht euch im wirklichen Leben Angst? Dann hätten wir sehr viel mehr Anrufer.
Dann lass uns die doch einfach stellen.
Was macht ihr denn im wirklichen Leben Angst?
Wir können doch gucken, wie viel von den Ängsten, die da draußen herrschen, wir ins Internet übertragen können.
Anni, ich rede mit dem Anrufer. Über dein Name Philipp?
Ja.
Was macht ihr denn im richtigen Leben Angst? Nazis?
Kinderpornos?
Bundestagswahlen? Bundestagswahlen?
Nee, die halte ich eher veralbern. Aber, ähm, naja, also Job und Geld. Und einfach das Überleben in der heutigen Gesellschaft.
Überleben macht ihr Angst?
Glaubst du, dass das Internet als solches, als gesellschaftliches Ereignis, das dir bei diesen Ängsten beistehen kann? Also wird es dadurch besser oder wird es dadurch nicht besser? Ich weiß, dass wir das letzte schon mal hatten. Ich will das jetzt trotzdem fragen.
Hm, es wird nicht besser. Es verschleiert vielleicht die Realität ein bisschen und hilft.
Aber ist es nicht einfach so, dass das Internet, was mit uns die Menschheit kreiert ist, und die reelle Welt ist es ja nun nicht, also zumindest nicht 100%ig, und deswegen haben wir den Ahnung, wir können es besser kontrollieren und deswegen macht es uns weniger Angst. Also ich stelle jetzt mal so einen Raum hier kurz vor Nachrichten.
Ja, dann hätte ich vielleicht noch eine Frage besser gesagt.
Also das, was am meisten im Hintergrund läuft die ganze Zeit, ist ein japanischer DJ.
Ich bin enttäuscht.
Nein, siehst du, ich sag die Musik ist geil. Ich sag jetzt Philipp, was das für eine Musik ist. Also das, was die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund während wir reden läuft, ist Ken Ishii. Das ist ein japanischer DJ, der eine Doppel-LK rausgebracht hat, die heißt Jelly Tones. Und ansonsten haben wir gehört von Andi...
Nee, nicht von mir.
Mikroglobe. Mikroglobe. Ist das ein Sampler? Nee, ne? Nee, das ist Mike van Dyke Presents. Ich kenne das nicht. Und was haben wir noch gehört? Ähm, warte.
Wir können ja die Liste ins Laptop.
Slap haben wir gehört. Toll, dann muss ich das alles aufschreiben. Und Paul van Dyke haben wir gehört. Paul van Dyke, so heißt er. Und jetzt hören wir noch ein bisschen Fateless, bis zum Kurzinfo.
Moment.
Was denn?
Die Homepage.
Ja, machen wir Nachhakeninfo, okay?
Okay, und kommt jetzt die Schnulze?
Jetzt kommt die Schnulze für dich.
Für Marianne.
Für Marianne. Philipp, ich dank dir. Bis dann. Jetzt kommt die Schnulze, pass auf. Wunderbares Album von Faithless, Don't Leave heißt der Song.
Wenn Fritz in Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
23 Uhr, 32.
Kurz Info.
Aktionsprogramm, die Teilnehmer des ersten Weltkongresses gegen Kindesmissbrauch haben in Stockholm einen Plan gegen......dass es sich hierbei um ein paar Geschenke von im letzten November entlassenen Mitarbeitern handelte. Cybervoting. Der Schweizer Bundesrat hat Aufforderungen abgelehnt, darüber nachzudenken, die schweizerischen Volksbefragungen im Internet stattfinden zu lassen. Der Bundesrat vertritt die Meinung, dass Computernetze zu anfällig für Angriffe sind, von überall in der Welt. Cyberhack. Die Homepage der US-Justizbehörde präsentierte sich ein paar Stunden unbemerkt in neuem Gewand. Einem Hacker war es gelungen, die Homepage komplett auszutauschen. In der neuen Variante gaben sich Adolf Hitler samt Hakenkreuz und dünn bekleideten Damen ein. Stell dich ein auf der gut besuchten Internetseite. Böse Kommentare zum Communication Decency Act ergänzten das Kabinettstückchen. Der Hacker ist noch unerkannt.
Nee, wir haben auch keine Fragen gestellt. Machen wir gleich. Diese Diskussion um die Musik immer, ja. Wenn hier irgendwie atmosphärische, elektronische Musik läuft zum Thema passend, hm, was ist denn das für Scheiße, spiel ich einen tollen Popsong hier von Sveit. Jetzt schalten alle ab, echt. Nicht zu fassen, echt.
Hörst du irgendeinen Hörer?
Ich nicht.
Ich höre ganz viele. Wir machen weiterhin unser Voting. Wir fragen euch, wovor habt ihr im Internet am meisten Angst? Telefonnummer ist in Berlin 25 44 92. Und dann folgende Ziffer. Die 20 für CNN und CIA. Die 21 für die Unüberschaubarkeit. Die 22 für die Bundesregierung. Die 23 für abgehört werden. Die 24 für Bild online. Die 25 für schleichende Vereinsamung. Die 26 für nichts. Und die 27 für keine Ahnung. So bis um 1 Uhr, bis hier der Nightflight losgeht, wollen wir mit euch allerdings noch darüber reden, was wir euch zur Verfügung stellen sollen auf den Chaosradio-Homepages, die jetzt einen Anfang genommen haben. Die Adresse ist www.artkom.de Also A-R-T-C-O-M www.artkom.de slash CCC slash Chaosradio In einem Wort mit CH. Guckt euch mal kurz an, wenn ihr eine Telefonleitung frei habt und ruft uns hier an oder schickt uns eine Mail natürlich, das geht auch, chaos.orb.de Ruft uns an, was wollt ihr für Informationen auf diesen Seiten haben und wie könnt ihr eventuell selber daran beteiligt sein. Was habt ihr für Informationen, die ihr gerne in die Chaosradio-Seiten einbinden wollt oder was habt ihr für Haustiere, die ihr unbedingt zur Verfügung stellen wollt. Wir können uns dann anrufen. 0331-74-81-110 Was meint ihr eigentlich zu diesen ganzen persönlichen Homepages? Also es stolpert ja jeder drüber. Ist das ein notwendiges Übel? Muss das trotzdem sein oder nicht?
Das ist ein interessantes gesellschaftliches Phänomen. Das ist eine große Sache. Man kann das schlimm finden, aber ich denke das Schlimmste finden nutzt überhaupt nichts. Es ist einfach so, dass wohl ein großes Bedürfnis dafür besteht, dass die Leute sich selber präsentieren und halten das zunächst einmal auch für vollkommen in Ordnung. Manchmal kommt dabei ja auch was wirklich Tolles zustande. Es gibt wirklich sehr viele sehenswerte Homepages. Mittlerweile gibt es auch schon sehr große Verzeichnisse im Netz, die fast ausschließlich Homepages referenzieren. Und ich denke, dass es auch für viele Leute eine wirtschaftliche Chance ist. Wir haben ja schon hier bei vielen gehört, dass sie einfach durch Aktivitäten im Internet dann eben mit einer Homepage relativ einfach auch einen Ansprechort schaffen können für sich am Hafen, wo die Leute irgendwie einlaufen können. Und diese Möglichkeiten hätten sie vorhin gehabt. Und im Internet sind zunächst einmal alle gleich.
Ich finde es erstaunlich, ich habe dann auch so ein paar Seiten mit diversen Kram, die man so macht im Laufe der Zeit und habe das nicht groß publiziert oder so. Und ich habe neulich erst einmal so herausgefunden, wie ich wirklich nachgucken kann, von wo die Leute darauf geguckt haben und auf welche Seiten genau. Ich bin ja nicht so der Unix-Track und habe mir das zeigen lassen. Und das hat mich schon überrascht. Also ich dachte, das sind halt hauptsächlich Fritz-Hörer, die sich mal interessieren, was macht der Kerl so oder so. Und obwohl das in keiner Suchmaschine groß drin ist oder in irgendwelchen, da gibt es auch nicht viele Links zu, hat mich das doch überrascht, dass da nicht nur ein Dutzend Leute, sondern wirklich hunderte von Leuten geguckt haben und dann auch durchgesteppt sind. Also da sind ein paar Interviews drin und so. Sich das scheinbar zumindest diese Seite angewählt haben, ob sie es gelesen haben, weiß ich ja nicht.
Wahrscheinlich alles Robots.
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Alles automatische Suchmaschinen. Aber insofern denke ich schon, dass es da eine Chance gibt für Leute, wirklich aus dem Wohnzimmer heraus auf sich aufmerksam zu machen und mit einer noch so kleinen Dienstleistung dann eventuell auch sich eine andere Zukunft vielleicht zu basteln.
Das heißt, du glaubst auch, es wären alle arbeitslos und finden dann in der Branche Arbeit?
Ich bin jemand, der schon vor Jahren sich mit Hippies rumstreiten musste, die gesagt haben, Computer sind scheiße, weil sie nehmen Arbeitsplätze weg. Und ich habe immer gesagt, dass die Arbeit, wo Computer so am schnellsten eingesetzt werden, nämlich zum Beispiel bei Fließbandarbeit, da bin ich eigentlich, auch wenn es übergangsweise weh tut und natürlich schlecht ist, aber da bin ich froh, wenn das nicht mehr Menschen machen müssen. Wenn du einmal jemanden gesehen hast, der seit 30 Jahren am Fließband steht, dann weiß ich nicht, warum der nicht so schnell wie möglich durch eine Maschine hergesetzt wird.
Und außerdem darf man in Wohnungen kleiner als 12 Quadratmeter nicht wohnen und deswegen müssen die Leute, die da drin wohnen, jetzt leider auf der Parkbank schlafen.
Den Zusammenhang habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden. Also komm, das ist wirklich kein Vergleich, Steini. Ich habe den Zusammenhang nicht verstanden. Also ich meine, das was Johnny sagt, das ist im Prinzip genau Standesladen-Lehm. Wenn sich eine Tätigkeit durch eine Maschine ersetzen lässt, dann sollte sie durch eine Maschine ersetzt werden.
Nur dann, wenn das Sozialgezüge so funktioniert, dass die Leute dann trotzdem weiter existieren können.
Ja natürlich, aber die Form, wie wir irgendwann mal existieren, die ist ja noch überhaupt nicht gegeben. Also zum Beispiel, wir plädieren immer alle auf Arbeit. Und das natürlich nur, weil wir unser Essen und unsere Wohnung finanzieren müssen. Aber prinzipiell ist es doch völlig genial, wenn wir weniger arbeiten.
Na klar, vor allem wenn wir nur das tun, was uns Spaß macht. Aber deswegen frage ich ja, ob das heißen kann. Und das war ja genau meine Frage an dich, ob du glaubst, dass die Leute, die jetzt das wegen ihrer Arbeit verlieren, denn daran Spaß finden, einfach weil sie plötzlich Zeit haben, um im Internet zu surfen, und daran Spaß finden und ihre Homepage machen und darüber einen Job finden und das alles so ein bisschen lockerer wird.
Nee, das werden die Leute natürlich leider nicht schaffen, aus der Historie ihres Lebens, aber ihre Kinder vielleicht. Oder deren Kinder. Und das muss man wirklich weitläufiger sehen. Also ich glaube nicht, dass jemand, der mit 50 seinen Job verliert, dass der sich sagt, ok, dann bastle ich jetzt eben meine Homepage und fange an irgendwie Mobiles zu bauen. Das funktioniert nicht, natürlich nicht. Aber es ist auch falsch zu brüllen, wenn wirklich Jobs, die Menschen unwürdig sind, verloren gehen. Das muss man leider im großen Rahmen sehen. Also meiner Meinung nach ist das eine sehr persönliche Meinung, die ich hier wiedergebe. Das muss man auf längere Frist sehen. Und ich glaube, dass unter anderem das Problem ist, ich glaube, dass ein Staat zum Beispiel wenig Interesse daran hat, dass die Menschen mehr Freizeit haben, weil diese Freizeit muss gefüllt werden. Und je mehr Freizeit du hast, desto mehr kannst du nachdenken und so weiter und so weiter.
Naja, aber ich meine, dann wäre doch zum Beispiel gerade das Internet ein Diskussionsforum, um sich darüber auszulassen, wie man denn die Umgebung schafft, dass man tatsächlich Menschen unwürdige Jobs beseitigen kann. Durch Automatisierung und eben dadurch, dass man auch nicht mehr ständig auf Arbeit fahren muss und die Straßen verstopft, sondern dass alles prima von woanders ausgeht und welche Konsequenzen, und das wird ja kommen, das hat, wenn man denn tatsächlich den ganzen Tag zu Hause vor der Glotze sitzt und da seine Arbeit macht.
Ich denke, dass es auch der Aspekte auf der Cebeturm noch fehlt, weil da ist irgendwie rein so die Geschichte von wegen ja im Prinzip die Unterhaltung oder eben den Fernseher, die Freizeit irgendwie vor dem Netz verbringen und sich da irgendwie Seiten angucken und eben noch nicht so sehr das Ding im Prinzip auch als einen Arbeits-Lebensraum sonst wie zu sehen, weil so wird es ja aussahen. Also wenn wirklich überall Terminals sind und wenn wirklich alle Tätigkeiten, die man durch eine Maschine ersetzen kann, durch eine Maschine ersetzt sind, wo sind wir denn dann? Also ich meine, ich finde das schon sehr spannend, weil die Frage ist, ob wir die Bundesregierung überhaupt noch brauchen zum Beispiel.
Ja vor allem oder ob sich dann auch nicht diese ganzen Jobs, die man im Internet machen könnte, nicht auch automatisieren lassen, also ob es nicht Werbung dann völliger Quatsch ist, weil Produkte nur noch durch ihre Qualität existieren, ob Leute nur noch, wenn sie kompetent sind, auch gehört werden, bzw. solche Mechanismen sich da einpegeln, ob die letzten Endes die ganzen Jobs auch noch beseitigt werden.
Vielleicht kann man den Internet-Surfer auch durch eine Maschine ersetzen.
Ja zum Beispiel, ich meine gibt das ja schon.
Super, dann amüsiert sich die Maschinen gegenseitig übereinander.
Ja und dann können wir alle Freie Liebe praktizieren.
Nein. Doch, weil wir haben jetzt von einem Menschen gelesen, nämlich die Fritz-Nachrichten. Man muss den Fritz kurz informieren, man muss den Fritz im Netz.
Dann www.fritz...
Ja, das ist wohl wahr. Wir geben euch gleich nochmal sämtliche Adressen, die ihr braucht und wo ihr erhältst, um völlig durcheinander zu kommen.
Und das nächste Mal bereiten wir uns vor.
Ja Andy, das ist jetzt... Ich mach mal das Mikro aus.
Ich mach mal das Mikro aus.
So, wir haben das Voting aufgelosen. Wir haben euch gefragt, wovor habt ihr im Internet am meisten Angst? Weit vorne, nee nicht so weit vorne, mit 28, 6 Prozent vorne liegt, abgehört werden. Dafür haben also zumindest mehr als ein Viertel der Leute Angst, die angerufen haben. Warte mal, ich muss das Voting erstmal stoppen, sonst verfälscht das das Ergebnis.
Das ist natürlich interessant, weil das hat kaum einen Anrufer bis auf einen tatsächlich zur Sprache gebracht.
Da sind sie alle abgehört worden.
Zum Schluss, ja. Gut, also jetzt haben wir das Endgut, ach guck mal, jetzt hat sich dann noch ein Guss geändert.
Echt alles wieder neu?
Ja, das ist natürlich jetzt blöd, weil ich das gerade erst gestoppt habe. Jetzt haben wir 34 Prozent bei der, hä?
Das rechts mit dem Kabel ist die Maus.
Kann der Internet-Experte gerade noch mal den berühmten Satz sagen, die technischen Probleme sind gelöst?
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann da nicht rüber die Konsole gucken.
Du brauchst es doch nur zu sagen.
Nein, ich hab's jetzt.
Also 28, 6 Prozent haben Angst davor, abgehört zu werden. 19 Prozent haben vor Bild-Online Angst und ebenfalls 19 Prozent haben keine Ahnung, wovor sie Angst haben. 14, 3 Prozent haben vor der schleichenden Vereinsammung Angst und jeweils 9, 5 Prozent haben Angst vor CNN und CAA und der Unüberschaubarkeit des Netzes. Vor der Bundesregierung hat damit niemand Angst und vor nichts hat auch niemand Angst. Gut, soviel zum Voting. Vielleicht nochmal die ganzen Adressen, wo ihr uns erreichen könnt. E-Mail ist chaos.orb.de. Chaos mit CH bitte. Tim vielleicht nochmal die URL, wo die Chaos-Seiten im Moment liegen. Die Chaos-Radio-Seiten. www.art.com.de-ccc-chaosradio Ja, nutzt das bitte ausführlich und zwar hauptsächlich dazu, um uns zu schreiben, was ihr auf diesen Seiten sehen wollt, welche Infos ihr wollt und welche Infos ihr uns zur Verfügung stellen könnt, um daran mitzubasteln.
Genau. Ab morgen auf der Homepage dann auch die Information, was wir nächste Folge machen. Nächsten Monat.
Was machen wir da?
Nächsten Monat, das ist jetzt Premiere. Wir wissen nämlich diesmal schon, was nächsten Monat dran ist. Nächsten Monat kommen Verschwörungstheorien. Und zwar fängt das an irgendwie im vorkristlichen Zeitalter und hört dann vielleicht mit solchen Geschichten um den TVA-Absturz auf mit vielleicht Estonia-Versenkung oder Titanic oder welchen Theorien, die man aufstellen kann, warum manche Dinge vielleicht doch merkwürdiger sind, als sie zu sein scheinen. Wir werden uns über alles unterhalten, was irgendwie komisch ist auf dieser Welt.
Gut, und allgemeine Informationen zum Chaos Computer Club gibt es wie immer unter www.ccc.de bzw. gegen Rückporto, ein Probexemplar der Zeitschrift Datenschleuder bei Wo jetzt die neue Ausgabe erschienen ist? Ganz genau, beim CCC Schwenke Straße 85 in 20255 Hamburg, 5 Mark in Briefmark.
Die Datenschleuder kaufen kann man auch in einem Laden in Berlin, das ist Orange Age in der alten Schönhauser Straße. Das ist der einzige Laden, wo man die käuflich erwerben kann.
Und der von Steinys Freunden betrieben wird.
Überall sonst gibt es das kostenlos.
Noch was?
Nein.
Gut, das war's mit Chaos Radio, morgen gibt's einen Blue Moon mit Tommy Wosch zur CeBit Home und mit Live-Schaltung zu CeBit selber. Das war Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club, gleich gibt's ab 1 Uhr den Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf, ich heiße Jonny und ich sag Tschüss. Da war meine Stelle, mein Einsatz.
Shouting lager lager gleich drei Minuten nach eins.
Mosch, wichtigstes Computersystem der letzten 20 Jahre für dich. Das ist noch kein Computersystem, aber ich find es schön, dass du das sagst. Computer Blumen bei Fritz, das heißt wir reden über Computer und heute wirklich über Computer, sonst haben wir oft Themen, die ideologisch damit zusammenhängen oder kulturell damit zusammenhängen oder soziologisch damit zusammenhängen, war schön ausgedrückt, ne? Heute reden wir über Computersysteme, über Betriebssysteme, über den Glaubenskrieg bei den Computern. Ich sag erst noch einmal, wie das Voting funktioniert und dann werden wir ein bisschen mit euch im Telefon plaudern. Es gibt eine Grundnummer, die ihr anwählen müsst und dann eine zweizifferige Endziffer für das entsprechende Computersystem, dass ihr für das Wichtigste der letzten 20 Jahre haltet. Die Grundnummer ist in Berlin 030254492. Und dann bitte die folgenden Endziffern, also nicht alle, sondern nur eine. Die 10 für Commodore Amiga, die 11 für Atari ST, die 12 für Apple Macintosh, die 13 für IBM PC und Kompatible, die 14 für Apple II, die 15 für Next, die 16 für Commodore C64, die 17 für Sinclair Computer, die 18 für Vax und die 19 für KC85-3. Und jetzt werden wir sehen, was ihr dazu meint. Hi, hier ist Chaosradio. Wer ist da?
Hallo, als erstes möchte ich mal vor der Benutzung des Slogans IBM-Kompatibel warnen.
Ah ja, nämlich.
Na ja, IBM will doch jetzt auf seine alten Patentrechte pochen und zwei bis drei Prozent des Umsatzes sämtlicher IBM-kompatiblen PCs verlangen.
Na ja, kann mir egal sein. Ich bin ja kein Hersteller. Ich darf das dann sagen.
Auf welche Patente soll sich denn das beziehen?
Soviel ich weiß und ich gelesen habe, haben Sie sich den Namen IBM-kompatibel geschützt?
Nee, nee, das ist noch ganz anders. Das geht dabei darum, dass es gewisse Funktionen in jedem IBM-kompatiblen Computer gibt, die von IBM als Schützenswert mal eingetragen wurden. Unter anderem zum Beispiel die Routine, die beim Anstarten des Rechners feststellt, was dafür Diskettenlaufwerke eingebaut sind. Also ob das jetzt ein 5, 25 Zoll 720 Kilobyte-Laufwerk ist oder tatsächlich ein 1, 44 Megabyte-Laufwerk. Braucht man heutzutage natürlich nicht mehr, zumal man das hier einbaut. Aber diese Routine, die ist halt in dem Rechner fest eingebaut und dafür möchte IBM jetzt Lizenzgebühren haben, wenn man diese Routine eben bei sich drin hat. Und solche Sachen sind es. Also es handelt sich nicht um IBM-kompatibel, sondern um Kleinigkeiten sozusagen.
Na gut, dann geht es ja noch nicht, dass nachher der Sender irgendwie...
Ach nee, außerdem haben wir es ja.
Wir haben ja eine riesen Rechtsabteilung und so. Da haben wir überhaupt keine Angst für. Was benutzt denn du für einen Computer? Und würdest du das auch als das wichtigste Computersystem der letzten 20 Jahre bezeichnen?
Durchaus.
Warum?
Weil ich der Meinung bin, dass er mit die weiteste Verbreitung gefunden hat, zumindest in den letzten Jahren.
Aber macht ihn das auch wichtig?
Würde schon sagen, weil ich weiß kaum, weiß nicht davon, dass es in irgendwelchen Firmen, außer mal abgesehen von Terminates, eigentlich außer Mac oder PC andere Computersysteme gibt.
Aber zum Beispiel, unter wichtig, stelle ich mir eher vor, wenn ich mir die Frage stelle, hat dieses Computersystem Leute kreativer gemacht oder schneller arbeiten lassen oder zum Durchbruch bestimmter Technologien geführt? Zum Beispiel, und da ist doch die Antwort beim PC dreimal neun.
Ne, das ist nicht wahr.
Das ist auch eine Frage.
Natürlich.
Also die PCs haben zumindest zu einer extremen Demokratisierung dieser Technologie beigetragen, weil sie einfach durch die Massenverbreitung billig geworden sind. Also das lässt sie sicherlich nicht bestatten.
Interessanterweise spiegelt der momentane Stand des Voting in keinster Weise den Marktanteil und die Verbreitung von Computersystemen aus.
Das ist allerdings sehr überraschend und sehr schön, finde ich. Also unser Voting, was hier noch läuft, das ist doch sehr verteilt, möchte ich mal sagen. Das finde ich spannend. Also ich dachte, als PC irgendwie 80 Prozent und alles andere unterfahren liefen. Aber nein, das spiegelt nicht unbedingt die Besitzverhältnisse wieder. Philipp? Dann bleib dran und hör dir dann an, was die Hörer alle gemeinsam denken, was das Wichtigste betrifft, was das Computer-System war oder ist. Wolltest du mal was sagen? Dir auch. Und schau. Du bist ein freundlicher Hörer, so wie wir sie lieben. Hallo, Chaos Radio hier. Ein freundlicher Hörer oder Hörerin? Silvio, hallo.
Ja, ich bin da auch mit beschäftigt, was so Computer angeht, beruflich. Und ich denke mal auch, dass die X86 vom Prozessor her, vielleicht nicht unbedingt vom ganzen Computer, aber vom Prozessor her, irgendwo eine ganz wichtige Stellung eingenommen hat. Was die ganze Entwicklung angegangen ist, das fing ja da mit einfachen Büroanwendungen an und hat sich dann so dermaßen entwickelt, dass man heute, finde ich, so die meiste Hardware, die man so kriegt und auch die meiste Softwareunterstützung von den Herstellern einfach mal bei den sogenannten IBM-Kompatiblen da kriegt. Und ich hoffe mal und ich denke, dass das nicht so darauf beschränkt bleibt, weil ich bin der Meinung, dass da auch ein bisschen noch andere Plattformen eine Chance haben sollten. Und da ist glaube ich Java als System ein guter Weg dorthin. Weil Java eigentlich systemunabhängig läuft und weil sich im Prinzip eher die Features, die er an seinem Rechner so schön findet, wie er so einen Brauch weiter nutzen kann und trotzdem mit anderen Nützern in Kontakt treten kann. Und im Prinzip das ganze Rechnersystem nachher, die eigentlich eine sekundäre Rolle spielt.
Du hast gesagt, du hast beruflich mit Computern zu tun, habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Ja, das ist...
Was machst du da speziell?
Ich repariere die Teile da und zwar bei der Eisenbahn.
Bei der Eisenbahn? Wofür setzt denn die Bahn? Alles Computer ein?
Ja, das ist ziemlich alles. Das geht von der Transportvorbereitung über normale Bürokommunikation bis nachher so Sachen, ein großes Uniksystem für den Fahrkartenverkauf und...
Wegstreckenplanung.
Kurz 90, dann ist jetzt als neues ein Transportsystem 90. Also im Prinzip unheimlich viel. Das Ganze wird jetzt demnächst noch größer weiter. Dort wird ein sogenanntes BKU eingeführt. Da gibt es noch eine Internetseite zu. Das nennt sich Bürokommunikationen unternehmensweit. Und da soll dann auch eine richtige Internetanbindung stattfinden.
Das heißt, ich kann über Internet meinen Sitzplatz auch buchen?
Ja, das kann man so sehen. Ich meine, dieses BKU ist im Moment eigentlich firmenintern. Also Bürokommunikationen unternehmensweit.
Über das Internet.
Man kann jetzt schon seine Platzkarte buchen. Da sind mehrere Dienste, die das durchaus erlauben.
Ja, aber die Bahn macht das selber leider noch nicht. Die Bahn hat auch immer noch komischerweise das Selbstverständnis, dass Leute dafür bezahlen müssen, dass man weiß, wann die Züge losfahren.
Wenn wir einen Experten dran haben, mich würde interessieren, womit macht denn die Bahn so die wirklich kritischen Sachen, weichen Stellen und solche Sachen?
Ja, da sind spezielle Systeme geliefert von Siemens. Das basiert da alles auf richtig Spezialrechnern.
Darf ich da mal einhaken? Es gab doch diese schöne Geschichte von diesem Hamburger großen Stellwerk, wo korportiert wurde, dass das wohl ein PC-System war. Da hatten sie doch gewisse Einführungsprobleme, was dazu geführt hat, dass durch Hamburg kein Zug mehr durchfahren konnte. Das habe ich gehört.
Das war aber eben Hamburg. Ich weiß nicht, ob man da ein PC-System eingesetzt hat. Zumindest hier in Magdeburg und auf der Strecke. Da läuft die Strecke 30. Vielleicht bekannt ist die Strecke von Hannover nach Berlin. Dort hat ganz wenig was mit PC zu tun. Es ist ein Spezialsystem, speziell auf diese Sachen ausgelegt.
Ein Name?
Es ging damals um Intel-Prozessoren. Ob das nur direkt PCs sind, weiß ich nicht. Aber es ging damals um Intel-Prozessoren.
Kurs 90 ist auf jeden Fall ein Unix-basiertes System.
Da gibt es so lustige Systemausfälle. Wenn man in Hamburg mit einem Funktelefon in den Kundenservice reingeht, da wird man gleich verscheuchten. Da sind auch große Aufkleber an der Tür dran, die hier nicht funktelefonieren, weil dann bricht die nach, wie ihr System weg ist. Das finde ich sehr lustig.
Zugentgleisung droht.
Das ist schon sehr eigenartig. Welche Probleme sind wir hier? Nicht bekannt, muss ich sagen. Das scheint da auch ein völlig anderes System zu sein.
Du hast aber hier gerade vier paar leuchtende Augen gesehen. Wir haben einen, der uns ein bisschen was erzählen kann, was da benutzt wird. Silvio, was ist denn der Fehler, den man am häufigsten reparieren muss oder beheben muss?
Anwenderfehler.
Sehr interessant.
Nenn uns doch mal ein Beispiel für einen Anwenderfehler.
Der am häufigsten gebräuchliche Anwenderfehler, den wir so haben, ist, dass der Drucker völlig streikt und nichts mehr geht. Dann kommt man hin und wechselt die Patrone aus und dann war's das.
Das ist auch wie eines, Anwender austauschen.
Ja, Anwender austauschen. Es gibt so eine schöne Sache mit der Hotline. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das kennt, wenn einer bei der Hotline anruft und sagt, hier steht, drücken Sie die Anikitaste.
Unsere Lieblingstaste.
Die kann ich nicht finden. Dann sagt der Anwender, nicht der Anwender, der Berater auf der anderen Seite, was steht denn auf Ihrem Monitor?
Okay.
Wir hatten übrigens bei der Überlegung, was wir nun zur Abstimmung preisgeben, auch überlegt abzustimmen, was denn nun dieses Anikit tatsächlich ist.
Ob das nun Space Return Enter oder Shift ist. Die Geschichte, die du gerade hast hier, ist doch eher so ein Klassiker, der wahrscheinlich in allen Firmen kursiert, die sich mit Computern auseinandersetzen. Du hast eine Menge Ahnung, du hast täglich damit zu tun, aber du kannst ja sicher auch einige Anwenderfehler verstehen. Also wenn Leute nicht unbedingt Computer geübt sind, ist ganz klar, dass man da Fehler macht, weil das doch ein bisschen eine andere Welt ist. Also liegst du da abends irgendwie zu Hause und denkst so, was mache ich hier eigentlich?
Das kommt dann speziell von solchen Sachen, habe ich auch festgestellt. Es kommen ja zu den Programmen für die normalen Anwender, die so draußen mit den Programmen arbeiten, immer so Beschreibungen, wenn sie zum Beispiel ein neues Programmteil oder neue Daten installieren sollen. Also einfach nochmal eine Datei einspielen sollen. Und die Beschreibung erstreckt sich dann meistens über drei bis fünf Seiten. Und wenn ich die selber dann durchgelesen habe, weiß ich auch nicht mal, was ich machen soll.
Da kommen wir wieder zum religiösen Aspekt. Ich stell dir mal was entgegen. Du hast vorhin so schön von einem Anwenderfehler gesprochen, wenn die Druckerpatrone alle ist. Ich meine, das ist ja wohl kaum ein Fehler des Anwenders, wenn der Drucker irgendwie auf einmal nicht mehr drucken kann.
Ja, nee, das ist richtig. Das ging ja um die Sache, was ich reparieren muss. Ich muss im Prinzip das Gerät wieder so hinstellen, dass es wieder funktioniert, also dass der Anwender damit machen kann, was er will. Und wenn ich als Anwender nicht mitkriege, dass die Patrone leer ist, ist das für mich doch schon ein Anwenderfehler. Weil das wird eigentlich überall signalisiert, jetzt hier halt wie Piep und...
Und was sagt denn der Computer, wenn die Patrone alle ist? Steht da etwas auf dem Bildschirm, wie die Patrone des Druckers ist alle?
Nein, aber auf dem Drucker selber ist dann entweder im Display erscheint Ink oder...
Ink.
Gut, jetzt muss man dem Anwender noch sagen, was Ink ist.
Das ist nämlich das Problem. Dieses Computersystem ist einfach nicht benutzbar.
Man darf nicht von einem Anwenderfehler sprechen. Kannst du denn... Was wollte ich denn sagen? Ich habe mich mit Ink total abgelenkt. Glaubst du denn, dass das immer noch Angst der Leute ist vor Computern? Dass zum Beispiel nicht einfach... Ich meine, wenn du da keine Angst vor hast, dann macht man den Drucker einfach mal auf und guckt nach, ob da vielleicht etwas ist, was man selber beheben kann. Haben die Leute noch viel Angst?
Die neue Bedrohung. Da hab ich aber schon...
Da gab's mal einen Drucker, der nennt sich NECP70. Vielleicht einigen Leuten so bekannt. Das ist ein riesengroßes Tier.
Klassik.
Und wenn wir den irgendwo hingestellt haben, bei einer Sekretärin auf seinem Rollwagen, dann hat die uns zwei Tage später wieder angerufen, wir sollen nochmal irgendwie vorbeikommen, der Drucker fährt durch die Wohnung da. Da haben die Leute dann schon Angst. Von der Warte aus ist das heute nicht mehr so. Die Rechner müssen einfach für die Leute funktionieren. Die Programme sind drauf, die kriegen eine Beschreibung, die lesen sie sich kurz durch, probieren dann, haben Anlaufschwierigkeiten. Aber danach geht alles solange gut, wie kein Fehler auftritt.
Und schönen Abend natürlich. Wenn wir so ein schönes Intro gehabt haben, so einen freundlichen Anrufer gleich am Anfang, den Philipp, dann wollen wir das auch so weitermachen. Hier ist eine Luft drin, das ist unglaublich. Sind wir das, oder ist es hier so warm? Ich hab gerade so schön alle vier vor mir gesessen, mit Papiergewebes.
Die Fritz Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam, 7481 Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Irgendwie bin ich der Auffassung, ich hab was vergessen. Ich hab mich schon in der DDR mit so einem Quatsch befasst. Das gab es nicht nur den KC 85. Sondern einen Haufen so CPM-Rechner, die es auch in der Bundesrepublik und auf der ganzen Welt gab. CPM ist das, was absolut den Durchbruch gebracht hat.
Ja, da hast du sicherlich nicht unrecht. Wie gesagt, wir haben selber abgestimmt, welche Rechner wir jetzt auf diese Liste nehmen. Und das war schon ein ziemlich heißes Gefecht. Mir würden auch noch zwei, drei einfallen, die auf jeden Fall eigentlich auf diese Liste gehören würden. Bloß andere Leute sind anderer Auffassung.
Aber CPM ist auf jeden Fall wichtig. Ja, es ging ja auch nicht so sehr um Betriebssysteme. Ich meine, CPM, da gibt es nicht so den klassischen Rechner, wo man sagen kann, das ist jetzt der CPM-Rechner. Ich meine, ich habe mit Northstar-Advantysch mal gearbeitet. War CPM mit hart sektorierten Disketten und so. Aber das sind halt alles so Sachen, naja.
Naja, die ganze Z80-Geschichte, worauf das passiert ist, ich habe mich in der DDR mit Robotron 1715 befassen müssen. Ja, ich muss wirklich sagen, ich habe dann danach beziehungsweise alle anderen PC-Generationen, auf jede Weise durch und nach, von XT bis zum Pentium.
Aber das Spiel werde ich absolut liebe.
Und das einzigste, wofür ich den 1715 noch immer noch auf meinem Schreibtisch habe, witzreicherweise, das nennt mich UFO. Und dann hoppelt es fliegt sehr so lang und schießt von den Dinger da ab.
Du hast sehr viel Platz auf deinem Schreibtisch, kann ich sagen.
Du bist relativ laboresistent.
Ich fand aber auch die Beschreibung des Spiels sehr schön. Man hoppelt dann da so lang und schießt seine Dinger ab.
Ja, aber genauso sieht das Spiel aus.
Ist das dieses mit der Mondlandung, wo man...
Ah, Duna-Lander.
Der Klassiker und der Grund, warum Unix erfunden wurde.
Ja, stimmt. Weil ja vorhin mal angesprochen wurde, Betriebssysteme. Also, ich würde sagen, bei Betriebssystemen sollte man sich einfach keinen Glaubenskrieg leisten. Jeder soll sich halt raussuchen, was für ihn das Beste ist. Also Unix ist, würde ich sagen, für die DFÜ Leute das Beste. Ist ja auch das, was sie man in Vermittlungsstellen benutzt.
Das wird sich irgendwann noch mal auszahlen, glaube ich.
War jetzt ein Witz über den ich lachen konnte?
Na ja, meines Wissens ist das nicht wirklich ein Unix, was die da fahren.
Also die Vermittlungsfunktionen an sich werden nicht unter Unix gemacht, sondern das Unix dient halt dazu, dass man dann hinterher schön die Gebühreneinheiten formatieren kann. Texto formatieren kann man ja mit Unix ganz gut.
Also richtig ist, dass in diesen Vermittlungsstellen tonnenweise 286er mit sperrigen Festplatten drin stehen. Aber das sind so eigene Systeme, das ist nicht wirklich Unix. Aber Kurs 90 von der Deutschen Bahn, das ist halt wirklich Unix. Sie nix.
Die SME wartet ja.
Aber was ist denn nun dein Lieblingsbetriebssystem, um jetzt mal langsam die Tonnen ein bisschen zu verschärfen und hier vielleicht ein bisschen die Gesetze herzukommen? Was ist denn das Beste?
Du hast sozusagen einen Ungläubige. Ein Atheist.
Du sollst nicht die Wahrheit sprechen.
Du sollst deinen religiösen Charakter verraten. Politist.
Den Glaubenist.
Also du bist eigentlich eher offen, nicht das Richtige.
Ich hab alles mal ausprobiert.
Ich kann sagen, OAS 2 halt ich für Schrott.
Auch als DFÜ Betriebssystem ist das eigentlich, finde ich, nicht so tauglich. Dann sollte man sich schon mit Unix beschäftigen, wenn man so eine Schicht machen will.
Harte Worte.
Aber nun ist es so, du sagst, du hast alle ausprobiert. Und so haben natürlich die wenigsten Leute die Zeit oder das Geld oder die Muße oder die Ahnung. Weil du sagst, jeder soll sich das aussuchen, womit er am besten klarkommt. Das ist natürlich nicht ganz einfach. Ich hab die Erfahrung gemacht, um bei den kleineren Heimsystemen zu bleiben, dass jeder, den man Mac neben einem PC zeigt. Das ist der eigentliche Grund für die Versatztum.
Ich halte übrigens OS 2 für ein ausgezeichnetes Betriebssystem, was weitaus besser ist als sehr viele andere PC-Betriebssysteme, vor allem Windows. Gründe? Hervorragende API, komplett durchdesigned, 32-Bit-Multi-Tasking mit sehr feinen Multisrading, da gibt es sehr viele Argumente, objektorientierte, vollobjektorientierte Oberfläche, alles solche Sachen, die Windows auch heute noch nicht hat. Und das zählt, nur hat es sich halt nicht durchgesetzt. Und man muss halt immer sehen, diese Geldgeschichte, das kommt immer noch mit rein und natürlich dadurch aufbauend auch diese Verfügbarkeit von Software, die mittlerweile der eigentliche Grund ist, warum Leute bestimmte Computersysteme kaufen. Da kann ich auch gar nicht gegen reden. Das ist leider genau der Punkt, genau. Und nur die Religion erlaubt einem Jahr dann auch andere Dinge zu betrachten. Da geht es halt nicht nur um Geld, sondern da geht es halt vor allem um die Gläubigkeit. Was ist denn nun das Beste? Und letzten Endes hat sie auch gezeigt, dass sie innerhalb von 5 Jahren auf dem Computer eine Menge ändern kann.
Deswegen magst du you nichts.
Und auch dir einen schönen Abend natürlich. Ich hoffe, dass ihr das immer mitkriegt, wenn ich so hier am abwürgen bin. Sollen wir nochmal die Votingnummern durchgehen? Das ist nämlich gerade so ein bisschen langsamer geworden. Wir haben auch nur noch 5 Minuten. Genau, 5 Minuten haben wir noch bei unserem ersten Voting heute Abend. Wir haben 3 verschiedene. Das erste stellt die Frage, was war oder ist das wichtigste Computersystem der letzten 20 Jahre für euch? Ihr wählt dazu eine Grundnummer in Berlin. 030254492. Und dann die folgenden Endziffern, je nachdem für welches System ihr euch entscheiden möchtet. Die 10 für Commodore Amiga, die 11 für Atari ST, die 12 für Apple Macintosh, die 13 für IBM PC und Kompatible, R im Kreis, TM im Kreis, weiß ich was. Die 14 für Apple II, die 15 Next, die 16 Commodore C64, die 17 Sinclair Computer, die 18 Vax und die 19 KC85-3, das ist übrigens, könnt ihr vielleicht nicht wissen, das ist ein altes Computersystem, gab es in der DDR, hat ungefähr 3000 Marke gekostet. Angeb. Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio, wer ist da? Na, menschlogisch eigentlich.
Ich musste erst mal sagen, also ich finde gar nicht gut, was du gestern für Musik gespielt hast, ja.
Ah, mit mir?
Ja, dachte ich eigentlich, weil ich höre meine Stimme auf dem Radio und darum dachte ich, ich spreche mit dir.
Die sind aber auch noch da.
So, und dir hat die Musik gestern nicht gefallen?
Nee, überhaupt nicht, weil ich hab mir bloß mit Monoradio, weil mein Strom im Moment noch nie an die Hand hinhaut, weil der Elektriker sich nicht hertraut und so.
Du hast Kuttner gehört und nicht den Soundgarden. Du redest von der Sendung, wo es links und rechts verschiedene Musik gab.
Genau, Kuttner wartet, genau.
Gut, dann musst du noch mal anrufen, wenn der dran ist. Danke dir. Hi, Chaos Radio hier, wer ist da? Micha ist schnell noch mal auf dem Pod gewesen.
Ich musste gerade das Radio wieder anmachen, weil mein Zeituhr die Radio gerade ausgeschaltet hat.
Ah, eine Radio weg.
Computer gesteuert sicherlich. Micha, ich musste mich jetzt auch mal zu Wort melden, weil die ganzen PC Leute mir langsam auf die Nerven gehen. So ein bisschen zumindest.
Ich lasse dich jetzt reden, hast 30 Minuten.
Also komm drauf an.
Gut, ich fange mal damit an, dass ich die frühe Entwicklung von Sinclair und sonstigen Geschichten nur mittelbar mitgemacht habe, weil ich in der DDR lebe und nicht so gut an so eine Sache herangekommen bin. Und ich habe irgendwann, Ende der 80er, will ich mal sagen, die Bekanntschaft mit dem Atari gemacht. Und ich muss sagen, ich bin immer noch Fan von dem Teil. Ich habe den halt ein bisschen getunt und ein bisschen da rumgebastelt. Und ich bin eigentlich da immer noch sehr zufrieden damit. Nur leider bröcke jetzt langsam die Software Schiene ein bisschen ab.
Sagen wir nochmal zwei Sachen, die du als herausstechendes Merkmal anführen würdest, die den Atari ST zu einem wichtigen Computersystem.
Ja, eins fällt mir auf jeden Fall sofort ein. Von wegen stehen nur PCs und Macintoshs in Firmen. Ich kenne also etliche Firmen, die DTP mit Ataris fahren, immer noch.
Siegenum, Kalamos.
Siegenum nicht so richtig, aber Kalamos halt. Also da gibt es wirklich eine Menge Profis, die damit immer noch fahren. Und die vielleicht mittlerweile die Hardware geändert haben, die jetzt mit dem Macintosh fahren, aber immer dann mit der entsprechenden Emulation dann immer noch Atari fahren.
Also ich denke, das ist aber dann doch wieder... Ich merke immer wieder, dass viele Leute Computer danach bewerten, welche Programme sie darauf haben. Und das ist eigentlich auch ganz klar, aber das System selber ist natürlich schon mal noch ein Unterschied. Denn Kalamos könnte genauso gut auch auf einem Macintosh oder einem PC laufen. Und sicherlich wird das auch auf einem von den beiden Plattformen demnächst verfügbar sein.
Aber ich denke, für einen Atari zum Beispiel spricht außer dem ersten What You See, What You Get, was sehr viel billiger als damals noch Apple Macintosh war, spricht auch noch zum Beispiel Musik. War der erste Heimcomputer, der wirklich günstig war mit eingebauten Midi-Schnittstellen. Und ich meine, gerade bei dem, was jetzt, guck dir die Charts an, das sind alles die Pop-Versionen von dem, was Techno so zumindest soundmäßig bewirkt hat. Und da hat der Atari sicher eine ganz, ganz große Rolle gespielt. Insofern ist der kulturelle Einfluss von so einem Rechner sicher sehr groß.
Und was mich halt da auch immer noch relativ fasziniert bei so ein Sachen, da können sicherlich andere Leute bloß von träumen, dass halt viele Atari-Firmen, die jetzt noch existieren, halt in Deutschland sind. Und dass ich mit vielen per E-Mail oder telefonisch-persönlichen Kontakt habe, dass ich denen meine Bugs schicken kann, dass die 1x3 behoben sind und dass ich teilweise auch Einfluss auf die Entwicklung der Programme habe. Und das ist einfach für mich ein enormer Vorteil.
Wobei, naja, der Atari-Markt ist ja nicht klein. Ich wollte gerade sagen, in einem riesigen Markt, wie es EWM-kompatible sind, nicht möglich. Wobei, da kommt es glaube ich auf die Firmen an. Ich glaube, es gibt sicher in jedem Betriebssystem da Firmen, die auf sowas auch Wert legen, dass die Kunden sich zurückmelden.
Ja, sicher.
Ich denke aber schon, dass er Recht hat. Und im Amiga-Bereich ist es sicherlich derzeit ähnlich. Also die Nähe zu Entwicklern, das ist auch wirklich nur zu leisten auf Plattformen, die nicht so hypermäßig verbreitet sind. Das ist schon beim Macintosh ein Problem. Obwohl er weitaus mehr verbreitet ist.
Und ich meine dadurch, dass der Atari von Hause aus nicht so arg mit RAM ausgerüstet war, sind die Programmierer natürlich auch dazu gehalten, effektivere Programme zu programmieren. Ich meine, man kann natürlich, man könnte sich auf dem PC-Bereich auch mit wesentlich weniger Speicher wesentlich effektivere Programme machen, aber ich sehe es zumindest so, dass die Programmierer einfach nicht die Zeit haben. Das ist der Zeitdruck viel zu groß, um da irgendwelche Optimierungen machen zu können.
Sie haben vor allem nicht die Werkzeuge dafür, dass das große Problem ist.
Ja, das ist das Werkzeugproblem, das stellt sich auf den kleinen Plattformen ja erst recht. Also gut, wenn jetzt so ein durchentwickeltes Programm wie Color muss auf dem ST die Maschine optimal ausnutzen und Ressourcen sparsam umgeht und so weiter, dann ist das sicherlich in der Historie begründet. Aber wenn man neue Software entwickeln muss oder will, dann stellt sich schon die Frage, wo kriegt man das beste Werkzeug? Und da stellt sich nicht mehr so sehr, ob das ein groß oder klein wird, das Programm hinten rauskommt, sondern es muss vielerfrei sein und vernünftig laufen.
Im PC-Markt zählt eher, dass das Werkzeug schneller auf dem Markt ist, als dass es einen Megabyte Speicher weniger verbraucht.
Ja, kostet auch ordentlich. Also ein Megabyte ist billiger als die Zeit, die man braucht, um mit Megabyte weg zu optimieren.
Ja, die Nischencomputer, das ist so eine Sache. Ich habe ja immer noch die Hoffnung, dass hier jemand anruft, der vielleicht mal für den Next eintritt oder ähnliches. Außerdem haben wir eine ganze Menge Amiga-Fans auf unserer Votingliste drauf.
Ja, aber das Voting ist auch zu Ende jetzt.
Das Voting ist zu Ende. Micha, ich danke dir erstmal. Und auch dir noch einen schönen Abend. Ich werde jetzt erstmal hier die Liste zu Ende schreiben. Ich spiele mal ein bisschen Musik und dann sage ich euch, was hier rausgekommen ist. Und das ist schon ziemlich hammer, finde ich das. Das ist doch nicht repräsentativ, umfragen, das geht doch nicht. Echt unfassbar. Wir sagen euch jetzt das Ergebnis des ersten Votings, sagen euch dann das zweite Voting an. Und telefonieren natürlich auch weiter mit euch. Ihr hört Chaos Radio, den Computerblumen bei Fritz. Chaos Radio bei Fritz, der Computer-Blumun bei Fritz. Wir führen den Glaubenskrieg bei Computersystemen und bei Betriebssystemen. Wir hatten das erste Voting in der ersten Stunde. Da ging es darum, was war oder ist das wichtigste Computersystem der letzten 20 Jahre.
Ich stelle das jetzt mal auf, was repräsentativ ist, was wir da haben.
Aber das schöne an diesem Voting-System ist, man kann es nicht bescheißen, außer natürlich wir würden uns jetzt hier hinsetzen und selber die ganze Zeit anrufen, aber das ist nicht unser Interesse, sondern überraschende Ergebnisse sind unser Interesse und den haben wir auf alle Fälle gekriegt. Vielleicht kann Frank mal das groß zusammenfassen.
Ja, also wir haben deutlich gemerkt, dass wir hier uns in Brandenburg befinden und dass die Reichweite des Senders für das zweite Kind im Bereich der ehemaligen DDR liegt. Wir haben als Sieger dieses Votings das obskure KC85-3-System mit 21, 2 Prozent. Platz zwei ist der Commodore Amiga mit 21 Prozent. Mit weitem Abstand der IBM PC bei 14, 4 Prozent, kurz dahinter der Apple Macintosh mit 12, 8 Prozent. Bei 8, 5 Prozent gelandet sind die Sinclair Computer, bei 7, 9 Prozent die Digitalex Computer.
Hier gibt es Hacker.
Ja, ein paar wenige abgeschlagene. Die C64-Gemeinde ist mit erstaunlichen wenigen 6, 3 Prozent, hat sich da zufriedengegeben. Der Atari kurz dahinter mit 5, 6 Prozent, die NEXT weit, weit abgeschlagen mit 1, 9 Prozent und das am wenigsten bekannte System in diesem Lande offenbar ist der Apple II mit 0, 3 Prozent.
Da hat sich IBM die Ideen geholt für den PC, das muss man auch nochmal dazu sagen, und zwar alle. Jetzt wäre es ja doch interessant, vielleicht kann ja mal jemand anrufen, der da mitgestimmt hat für die KC, sag mal die oder den KC? Für den KC 95, 3.
Strich drei.
Strich drei, Entschuldigung. Und mal so ein bisschen aus der Erfahrung erzählen, warum ist das das wichtigste Computersystem der letzten 20 Jahre? Würde mich jetzt doch stark interessieren.
Ja, mich auch.
Also es gibt einen wesentlichen Grund, das Betriebssystem dieses Computers hieß Chaos.
Wer hat ihn wohl zu den 300% geführt?
Ja, es war halt einfach so, dass es wahrscheinlich der Computer war, an dem die meisten Hörer im Sendegebiet ihre ersten Computererfahrungen gesammelt haben. Und von daher war es wahrscheinlich der prägendste Eindruck. Das System an sich war doch relativ obskur. Also es gab erst ganz zum Schluss 1989 dann eine Diskettenlaufe dafür. Und vorher musste man irgendwie seine Programme auf Kassetten speichern. Dann gab es diesen schönen G-Rekord-Recorder, den sicherlich noch viele Leute kennen werden. Der war also der klassische Aufzeichnungs-Recorder dafür. Und es gab sogar auf dem Vorvorläufer dieses Senders, als das ganze Ding noch DT64 hieß, Computersendungen, bei denen KC85-Programme über den Sender gesendet wurden von Herrn Prof. Völz.
Das müsste man mal wieder machen.
Ja, der hat dann halt, so irgendwie ich glaube mal Sonnabendnachmittags, haben dann alle vor ihren Radiorekordern gesessen und halt die Programme mitgetafelt und die dann mit schrägen Tonkaufeinstellungen an ihre Geräte gezwängt. Also es war sozusagen halt wirklich Software-Broadcasting und der hat dann glaube ich sogar noch soweit gegangen und hat derartige Programme auf Schallplatten gepresst, so diese Flex-Schallplatten, die so billig herzustellen sind, und hat die dann bei irgendwelchen Zeitungen dabei gepackt, was irgendwie doch deutlich vor dem Zeitall der beigelegten CD war.
Das war großartig.
Das war jedenfalls ein sehr innovatives System.
Das Problem ist, wir können das heute nicht mehr machen, weil ich mein, wenn so ein Programm vielleicht 50k hatte, dann ging das vielleicht irgendwie noch auf die Zeit.
50k, was wie lange es gedauert hat, 50k da runterzuladen. Ja, irgendwie auch schon Minuten, 10 Minuten hast du schon gesessen.
Naja, gedacht ich ja.
Also ich hab doch schon eine Weile gefloatzt und die Einschaltquoten sind wohl dramatisch eingeboren.
Ich wette, dass mich morgen mein hochgeschätzter Kollege Kuttner anruft und fragt, wie macht man das in der Sendung haben. Das klingt bestimmt klasse.
So können wir unser Gewinnspiel das nächste Mal durchziehen.
Ich hab noch einen Schuhkarton voll mit ZX-Programmen, die klingen genauso super.
Klingen tun die wahrscheinlich alle gleich.
Nein, man kann deutlich heraus hören, ob es sich um ein ZX-Spektrum oder um ein KC85 handelt. Es gab auch noch Turbo-Lader, wo man die Programme schneller von der Kassette laden konnte.
Wir haben zumindest mal in der Sendung die Fritz CD-ROM gespielt, eine Weile, das klingt auch ähnlich. Das war auch gut. Boxen-Killer. Wollen wir das nächste Voting ankündigen? Es gibt eine neue Frage, also bitte nicht mehr anrufen für die Computersysteme. Wir haben jetzt eine ganz ganz andere Frage, die natürlich auch mit Computern zu tun hat. Und da gibt es auch nicht ganz so viele Wählmöglichkeiten. Noch einmal die Grundnummer in Berlin, 030254492. Und dann folgende Endziffern. Die Frage lautet, wie viele Maustasten braucht ein Computer wirklich?
Das ist tief religiös.
Wie viele Maustasten braucht ein Computer wirklich?
Und denkt da genau über eure Antwort nach, bevor ihr abstimmt.
Genau, also erstmal alle Vorschläge anhören.
Ja, die 20 wählen hinten für keine Maustasten. Die 21 für eine Taste, die 22 für zwei Tasten, die 23 für drei Tasten und die 24 für 102 Tasten. Die Frage, wie viele Maustasten braucht ein Computer wirklich? Die Grundnummer in Berlin 030254492. Und folgende Endziffern, die 20 für keine Tasten, die 21 für eine Taste, 22 für zwei Tasten, 23 für drei Tasten, 24 für 102 Tasten. Und wir telefonieren hier natürlich weiter.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam, 74, 81, 110, 37.
Wieso geht eigentlich mal ein Netz-Gap jetzt hier nicht mehr mit dem Prozess?
Ja, irgendwie ist das Internet gerade ein bisschen breit.
Eure Internetanbindung ist grauenhaft.
Naja, das funktioniert nicht wirklich.
Rackart der Technik, du.
Machen wir gerne.
Chaos Radio hier. Hi, wer ist da?
Stefan.
Stefan, hallo.
Zu dem Thema hier, was ich vorhin habe, welches Briefsystem es ist, will ich was zu sagen. Ich habe zwei Jahre lang mit dem C64 gearbeitet. Habe jetzt seit wieder zwei Jahren nach wie Jahr. Und ich habe mich so beschäftigt mit Verwandten und Bekannten. Und habe ich herausbekommen, damit diejenigen, die in Verbindung mit Leuten sind, mit dem PC, auch ein PC kaufen. Und diejenigen, die in Verbindung sind mit dem Commodore oder SCOM und sonst was, sich dann so ein Gerät holen, weil sie etwas gesehen haben. Wenn ihr sagt, bloß diejenigen, die man sieht, die kann man auch auswählen. Es gibt genügend Zeitschriften im Fachhandel, wo man sich auswählen kann, was man haben will.
Ja schon, aber es ist doch bei den, also ich muss, ich finde das auch verständlich, wenn sich zum Beispiel jetzt ein Kollege X, Y hier bei Fritz fragt, was für einen Computer soll ich mir kaufen? Der hat einfach keinen Bock, drei Fachzeitschriften vorzulesen. Das interessiert ihn, das kann er auch verstehen. Der will einen Computer haben, der funktioniert, der eingerichtet ist, wo er seine Manuskripte drauf schreiben kann, ausdrucken kann, wo er vielleicht einen Internetzugang mit hat inzwischen, wo er vielleicht einen simplen Briefkopf mit erstellen kann und der einfach seinen gesamten Schriftverkehr speichert. Zum Beispiel für Journalisten, interessant. Der will nicht vorher die CT lesen.
Ist klar, würde ich ihn da fragen, was willst du damit machen eigentlich? Willst du Musik machen, willst du Grafik machen, willst du Texte bearbeiten, willst du E-Mail-Boxen aufbauen oder sonst was?
Wobei, das kann man ja heutzutage mit angegebenes Ding machen, ob das nur ums Internet geht.
Das hängt nur davon ab, wieviel man gerne auch leiden möchte.
Na ja, nun aber, desto komplexer desto mehr leiden, das ist unabhängig von dem eigenen System. Aber das mit der Einführung durch den Experten, den man kennt, der einem die selbst überzeugte Meinung dann auch überbringt, das ist natürlich immer der eigentliche Weg. Warum sollte man irgendeiner Fachzeitschrift vertrauen, wo es darum geht, mehr zu verkaufen, wenn man jemandem vertrauen kann, der so ein Ding zu Hause stehen hat und ausprobiert hat?
Wenn ich ein PC in der Zeitung sehe für 2000 Mark, da kann ich Lachen kriegen.
Was zahlst du? Sag mal so ein Vergleich. Du hast gesagt, du bist jetzt auf einem Amiga, ne?
Ich bin auf einem Amiga umgestiegen. Ich würde von meinem Rechner, wenn ich neu kaufe, jetzt 859 Mark bezahlen.
Mit Monitor.
Ich brauch keinen Monitor. Ich kann an einen Monitor ranhängen, ich kann aber auch an einen Fernseher ranhängen. Ich hab mal einen Fernseher dran, das reicht mir.
Da fängt das schon mal an. Jeder, der einen vernünftigen Monitor auf dem Tisch hat, wird dir sagen, im Fernseher kann man einfach absolut überhaupt nicht arbeiten. Und das würde ich auch so sehen.
Wenn man über Scout-Buchse geht, ist das wie im Monitor im Moment.
Na ja, das ist Interlaced. Du kennst das Problem beim Amiga.
50 Hertz. Wenn man über Scout-Buchse geht, ist kein Interlaced mehr da.
Na, dein Fernseher arbeitet aber Interlaced.
Ja, das sieht man aber erst bei Scout-Buchse nicht mehr, aber an Antennenbuchse sieht man es noch.
Scout-Buchse ist auch noch ein ganz normales RGB-Signal, erinnert sich gar nicht.
Also ich glaube, da kommt es wirklich, wie du schon selber sagst, Stefan, natürlich völlig darauf an, was man macht. Schreibst du sehr viel?
Ich bin eigentlich Programmierer, ich schreibe viel, ja.
Und das machst du echt am Fernseher?
Ja.
Wie dick sind deine Brillengläser?
Ich trage keine Brillengläser. Nein, auch nicht.
Nein, finde ich interessant.
Also ich habe doch gefragt, wie lange man aushält ohne Computer. Also wenn man richtiger Freak ist, ist eine Woche katastrophal.
Das ist auch eine schöne Frage. Wie lange hält man aus ohne Computer?
Ich fahre jetzt nächste Woche im Urlaub, also das ist schlimm.
Und welche Entzugssymptome hast du so?
Also sobald ich zu Hause bin, bin ich dran.
Ja, ich meine, wie geht es dir in der Woche?
Jeder kann mich händeln. Das ist katastrophal. Ich habe meine ganzen Daten, mein ganzes Wissen wird auch noch mal drauf.
Am Ferienort habe ich mir dann immer die gängigen Computerzeitschriften alle gekauft und durchgelesen. Und ein Manual ist mitgenommen. Das ist sehr, sehr hilfreich, auch um so die computerfreie Zeit zu überbrücken. Aber da war es ja früher besser mit den Spektrums und so, weil die konnte man tatsächlich einpacken und mitnehmen. Und das ist heutzutage echt schwieriger geworden.
Aber das ist doch zum Beispiel völlig schlimm, Anleitungen mitnehmen. Das mache ich also nicht, wenn ich nicht auch einen Rechner dabei habe. Weil du sitzt da mit der Anleitung und möchtest das unbedingt ausprobieren. Und was, das geht toll, muss ich ausprobieren.
Da kannst du dich mal richtig hibbelig machen, wenn du ein richtig schönes Dekanbuch reingezogen hast. Dann bist du gut drauf in den Haus.
Man lässt sich aber mehr Zeit, sich mit der Theorie zu vertiefen. Das ist schon ganz gut.
Wer von euch hat schon mal irgendeine Anleitung für ein Programm von vorne bis hinten gelesen?
Ich schon.
Welches Programm war das?
Failmaker.
Aber nicht Word.
Das sind ja keine Anleitungen mehr.
Word 3.0 irgendwie. Würde ich heute nicht mehr tun. Aber es empfiehlt sich.
Ja man, stellt auf MS-Fest das.
Es gibt doch dieses schöne geflügelte Wort irgendwie. Read that fucking manual.
Ja, Stefan. Was programmierst du so?
Ich erseim bloß Steuerung. Also mein Hobby ist Elektronik mit Computer zu verbinden, Autos selbst zu entwickeln und zu basteln, dann mit einem Kumpel zusammen die Software zu entwickeln. Da geht es nächtelang durch. Ich mache die Hardware, er macht die Software und dann wird so lange probiert, bis das alles klappt.
Und verkauft ihr das dann oder macht ihr das nur für euch beide?
Also noch so weit ist nicht zu verkaufen. Es gibt mehrere Prototypen-Projekte, aber direkt zu verkaufen ist noch nicht so weit.
Was steuert ihr denn damit? Was ihr damit steuert? Erzähl mal mehr.
Naja, extra eine Hardwarekarte für Schrittmaschurensteuerung, das softwaremäßig übermitteln, mit Daten, wo der Arm sie befindet, grafisch darstellen auf dem Rechner und so weiter.
Und was macht dann der Arm? Gießt er die Blumen?
Nein, alle bis zwei Achsen.
Interessant, was machst denn du beruflich?
Ich bin Elektriker, Energieinstituteur.
Das machst du den ganzen Tag und dann setzt dich nachts auch noch vor die Kiste?
Ja, den ganzen Tag, außer den Pausen. Dann hast du den Kopf heiß gemacht für die nächste Nacht.
Ja, dann kann man nur sagen, viel Erfolg dann.
Was ihr noch sagtet, was ist eigentlich das, was ihr am meisten braucht? Ich brauche das Preis-Leistungsverhältnis vom Rechner und dann was er alles dran hat. Grafik, 32-Bit-Rechner sowieso, dann 16 Millionen Farben, davon sind 4.066 gleichzeitig darstellbar, ist zwar interless, aber immerhin viermal 16-Bit-Soundkarten. Was haben wir denn nicht mehr? Er ist frei zu programmieren, nach außen. Wenn man als PC-User fragt, wie sieht es denn aus, kann es ein Amiga-Programm bitte lauffähig machen oder sowas, die erste Antwort, die sie sagen, ist nein. Wenn man die zweite Frage nachstellt, wie viele Spiele hast du, wie viele Disketten, sagen die 120 Disketten, ja wunderbar, wie viele Spiele sind es davon? 100. Die 20 sind das dritte Thema, das wir mitgegeben haben.
Also mein Computer kann von den 16 Millionen theoretisch darstellbaren Farben 16 Millionen darstellen gleichzeitig.
Theoretisch nicht möglich, guck mal deine Pixel auf dem Bildschirm nach.
Und?
Zieh mal durch. Ja, es ist ein selbstverständliches, theoretisch möglich, ich kann ja auch mehrere Grafikkarten in meinen Computer reinstecken.
Aber auf einen Bildschirm gleichzeitig darstellen, macht es ein bisschen schlecht.
Hängt ganz vom Bildschirm aus.
Ich glaube kaum, dass irgendein Bildschirm über einen Hammer 8 Modus zu überkommt.
Auf jeden Fall hat mein Bildschirm mehr als 4096 Pixel, wenn es drauf ankommt.
Ja, aber deine Grafikkarte, was macht die mit? In Verbindung mit dem Monitor?
Na, habe ich dir doch gesagt.
Die kann alles. Mein Computer ist der beste. Du kannst mir da gar nicht kommen. Mein Computer ist einfach sowieso besser als deiner. Gefragt hatte ich eigentlich, welches dieser Features dich wirklich glücklich macht. Ich meine 4096 hin, 4096 her. Was ist das, was wirklich Wonne in dir ausbreitet?
Hardware-Multitasking. Microsoft versuchte hier mit der Windows 95 da das Hardware-Multitasking hinzumachen. Das ist alles schön und gut. Der Versuch war fehlgeschlagen für mich, muss ich mal sagen. Aber Amiga hat schon ein S-Commet zu weitergehend, hat schon vorne reingeschafft, waren die ersten auf dem Markt, die Multitasking hatten. Echtes Multitasking.
Das ist richtig, aber das Multitasking von Windows 95 ist mittlerweile identisch.
Nicht nur der Versuch, sondern auch die Effizienz dazu. Ich sehe es beim Programmieren, wenn ich da 3-4 Versuche gemacht habe und 3-4 Programme irgendwo festgefahren sind, das fünfte, sechste läuft genauso schnell.
Naja, ich meine Multitasking ist beim Amiga auch wirklich der Punkt.
Ja, das ist das einzige, was mich am meisten interessiert.
Das macht dich glücklich.
Die Grafik läuft genauso schnell wie der Roboter an.
Stefan, ich danke dir erstmal. Und einen schönen Abend. Zumindest sind wir richtig schön drin im Glaubenskrieg, würde ich sagen. Das war schonmal ein erster Schritt. Einer der wenigen Glaubenskriege, die unblutig gefühlt werden, um das mal anzumerken. Und das hoffentlich erkennbare Augenzwinkern, wenn wir diesen Begriff benutzen, auch erkennbar zu machen. Aber ihr seid ja alle nicht blöd, ne? So, wo sind wir denn hier beim Fritz-Voting? Also ich sag nochmal die Grundnummer. Berlin 030254492, 254492. Die Frage lautet, wie viele Maustasten braucht ein Computer wirklich? Und die Endziffern, die ihr wählen müsst für die entsprechende Antwort, sind 20 für keine Tasten, die 21 für eine Taste, die 22 für zwei Tasten, die 23 für drei Tasten und die 24 für 102 Tasten. Oh, das ist ja ein interessantes Ergebnis bisher. Wobei ich ja auch... Na gut, da können wir gleich noch drüber reden, wenn es die Auflösung gibt. Wir werden auch noch ein drittes Voting haben nach 0 Uhr dann. Aber jetzt werden wir erstmal weiter telefonieren. Das kann man an Musik alles auflegen. Hier mein Freund, der Baum vielleicht? Noch irgendwas dazu sagen? Tim, willst du uns hier runterziehen oder? Ah, nicht die Kofferhöhre, offen ans Mikro. Alexandra mit meinem Freund der Baum. Wollte ich nur mal sagen. Achso, ja genau, die 19. Wir haben hier Fritz on Vote. Wir sind im Moment bei den Enziffern 20 bis 24. Der junge Mensch, der seine Wahlwiederholung auf der 19 hat, kann jetzt aufhören. Also er hat jetzt zwölfmal hintereinander angerufen und es zählt zwar noch mit, aber du kannst wirklich aufhören. Die 19 ist überhaupt nicht mehr im Rennen und zwar seit ungefähr 26 Minuten nicht mehr. Denn wir haben die Frage gestellt, wie viele Maustasten braucht ein Computer wirklich? Ihr könnt antworten und mitwählen, das ist ein ganz kurzer Anruf, dann wird er gespeichert. Die Grundnummer ist in Berlin 030 254492 und dann die Enziffer für die folgenden Antworten, die 20 für keine Tasten, die 21 für eine Taste, die 22 für zwei Tasten, die 23 für drei Tasten und die 24 für 102 Tasten. Bis zum Fritz-Kurz-Info, was gleich kommt, werden wir jetzt nicht mehr telefonieren, das lohnt sich nicht, wir wollen euch ja ausreden lassen, sondern wir machen Musik. Perfekter Computersong, Insomnia, I Can't Sleep von Faithless.
Wenn Fritz im Netz, dann www.fritz.de. Wir sehen uns.
Das ist Musik, die man damals New Wave nannte, aus Amerika erstaunlicherweise und die ich ultra schräg fand. Hans hat die Platte mitgebracht, Divo, Girl You Want. Eigentlich völlig poppig, wenn man es heute hört. Ich fand das damals richtig schräg.
Das war ganz schön schräg, ja.
Ich dachte so, uuuuh, Mann, sind die abgefuckt.
Dann lachen wir auch an den Kostümen und dann überhaupt an den Strumpfmasken und so.
Obwohl abgefuckt hab ich natürlich damals nicht gedacht. Ich dachte wahrscheinlich, auch so ein anderes, ob das politisch korrekt ist, wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Das soll er nicht erfunden. Wir kennen den Glaubenskrieg, den Computer Glaubenskrieg. Wir reden mit euch über Computersysteme und über Betriebssysteme. Was ist das Betriebssystem? Was ist das Computersystem? Warum glaubt ihr an das System, was ihr benutzt oder was ihr gerne hättet oder so? Das ist ja auch oftmals eine Geldfrage. Und außerdem läuft auch noch unser Voting hier im Chaos Radio. Ihr könnt eine Nummer in Berlin anrufen, da wird abgestimmt, geht ganz schnell, kostet nur eine Einheit, also spielt alle mit. Die Frage, die zurzeit läuft, noch bis zur vollen Stunde, bis um 9 Uhr, lautet, wie viele Maustasten braucht ein Computer, eurer Meinung nach wirklich? Ihr müsst dann die Grundnummer wählen in Berlin, 030, 254492, 254492 und dann die Endziffern, wenn ihr, je nachdem, welche Antwort ihr geben wollt, wie viele Maustasten braucht ein Computer wirklich? Die 20 wählen für keine Tasten, die 21 für eine Taste, die 22 für zwei Tasten, die 21 für drei Tasten. Die 24 für 102 Tasten, so muss der Satz lauten. Der Chaos Computer Club ist im Studio und meine Wenigkeit, mein Name ist Johnny. Und wir reden mit euch weiter und hören mal, was ihr so zu sagen habt. Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio. Knut, rufen wieder nur Typen an. Dann müssen wir ein Thema machen, das auf Frauen interessiert. Hallo Knut, ich treffe einen nicht gegen dich.
Ja, also ich wollte mich mal beschweren an den jungen Mann, der meinte er hätte den besten Computer. Also da muss ich jetzt mal einen Spruch erleben.
Ja los, steh an, was hast denn du für einen Computer?
Ja, ich hab einen PC.
Mit Isabus, ja.
Ja, wo man irgendwie die Konfiguration für jede Karte einzeln einstecken muss.
Neues Gigabyte Board mit Zitron, zwei Schlöppsatz geholt.
Immer noch mit dieser Slots.
Das klingt gerade wie ein Stück aus Paner durch die Galaxis.
Aber erzähl mal weiter, ich lasse euch jetzt hier ringfrei für Tim und Knut. Tim meint also sein Mac ist der beste, du sagst alles Blödsinn.
Kann ich dir nicht widersprechen. Sondern. Dann sag mir doch mal, was deinen Computer nicht von meinem Computer abgeguckt hat.
Also, äh, pass auf, mir ist völlig egal, was zuerst da war. Also, was mich interessiert ist, dass ich mit meinem PC einfach wahrscheinlich besser arbeiten kann. Ich, die Software, die ich haben will, mir umsonst irgendwo runterziehen kann, ich kenn auch keinen, der einen meckert. Wenn ich Software haben will, dann frag ich mal jemanden.
Ich kenn keinen, der einen meckert. Runterziehen heißt, du holst sie dir aus dem Netz.
Ich müsste jetzt nicht allzu konkret werden. Ich glaub, ihr wisst schon, was ich meine.
Na gut, also wenn es um Raubkopien geht, die kannst du auf jedem System dir besorgen. Sag dann noch mal kurz an der Straße.
Sicher nicht, aber der PC ist immer besser verbreitet. Und wenn ich irgendwas jetzt haben will, ein neues Programm ist, das rausgekommen ist oder so, dann bekomme ich das jetzt wahrscheinlich eher, als was ich dir die Info.
Ja, nur weil alle Leute Fiat Panda fahren, ist er ja nicht gleich besser als ein Mercedes. Das ist ja nicht das Argument und das ist auch nicht daraus, wo es geht. Keiner bestreitet, dass PCs besser verbreitet sind. Keiner bestreitet, dass die anderen Firmen nicht so klug gehandelt haben, wie es Microsoft und die ganze Intel-Maschinerie betrifft.
Ich bin zum Beispiel ein sehr zerstörender Kunde von Windows 95, wo gerade er mit seinem C64 meinte, das Multitasking wäre bei ihm besser. Ich stamme vorher vom Amiga und ich kann sagen, das Multitasking war im Prinzip ein Witz, rein von der Praxis her. Das war schon unter Windows 3.1 besser.
Bitte? Das ist nicht wahr.
Das ist deutlich nicht wahr.
Der Amiga hat ein sogenanntes preemptives Multitasking. Das heißt, er war in der Lage, die Programme zu unterbrechen, was ein wichtiges, wichtiges Feature ist. Und das konnte Windows 3.1 nicht. Deswegen bleibt es halt auch ab und zu mal stehen.
Ich sag mal eins, der Amiga ist derart leistungsunfähig gewesen. Und heute bittet sich halt auch noch, dass ich konnte, weiß ich jetzt nicht, in unserem Beziehungssystem jetzt irgendein Programm laufen lassen, das nächste daneben und in der Schallarbeit oder was ich war, das konnte ich mit Windows 3.1, wo ich mir meinen ersten 4.6.8.8.8 gekauft hatte, vorher bei Phobos 1.999 gekostet hat. Da habe ich für die Schule halt mein Englischprogramm gehabt, meine Textverarbeitung gleichzeitig und das wäre am Amiga mit Bäckertext überhaupt nicht möglich gewesen, da mit 50 Disketten die dann alle zu wegfüllen. Wir reden ja, wie war dein Name?
Also erinnerst du dich noch an den Anrufer vorhin, der mit dem Amiga, der macht so Steuerung und so?
Ja genau den mein ich.
Der braucht einfach diese Leistungsfähigkeit, die der Amiga uns tatsächlich hat. Und das geht halt mit Windows 3.1 nicht.
So mit dem Steuern und dem Regen und so.
Ich meine, niemand hätte andere Firmen davon wirklich abhalten wollen, genau die gleiche Software für den Amiga zu schreiben, wie sie es dann letztlich für Windows gemacht haben. Die Maschine hätte es durchaus zugelassen. Umgekehrt ist es allerdings nicht unbedingt so. Und das ist glaube ich auch das, was den Computer letztlich ausmacht, also was die eigentliche Qualität des Computers ausmacht, was theoretisch möglich wäre. Der Rest ist dann eigentlich nur noch Markt.
Aber ich finde das schon interessant, Knut, wenn du sagst, dass du also mit einem PC, dass du sagst, du kannst damit einfach alles machen, was du willst. Das kommt natürlich immer stark drauf an, was du machen willst. Und das einfach. Und das wage ich einfach echt stark zu bezweifeln. Weil das ist einfach, um mit einem PC einfach Sachen zu machen und ihn zu erweitern zum Beispiel selber, musst du unheimlich Ahnung haben. Allein der Umgang, und das fängt bei ganz kleinen Sachen an. Du musst dich mit kritischen Feilnahmen auseinandersetzen. Du musst Handbücher neben dir liegen haben und nachschlagen.
Interapflekturen, DMR-Kanäle einstellen.
Das stimmt zum Teil. Stimmt das nur aber auch nur zum Teil. Wir haben am AMIR mal versucht, da mal einen Scanner zum Laufen zu kriegen. Oder mit Scasi-Geschichten am AMIR was zu machen.
Also ich habe jetzt persönlich...
Hältst du natürlich am Macintosh? Keine Probleme. Heute kam einer mit einer Fotocd zu mir und war ganz überrascht, dass ich das Ding einfach bei mir eingelegt habe. Und dann konnte ich auch sofort auf die Bilder zugreifen. Und zwar mit jedem Programm und nicht nur mit irgendeinem.
Also ich habe mit Amiga auch keine Erfahrung. Deswegen halte ich mich da einfach raus, aber...